CORK HERE WORK IS HERE. SMITH
HERE SMITH IS HERE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HERE SHOWER CAN. DALLY
GARCIA BLUE BLOOM HERE. MATHIS
YOUR MATHIS HERE MODES TO CHEAT.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
FIVE MEMBERS. AND NOW WE HAVE
SIX AND THAT WE HAVE SIX SO SIX.
SIX CORN SO A GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC-
MATERIALS COMMITTEE HEARING-
WE'RE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. CHARLIE ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATING PERSON.
I AM AMAZED AT HOW WELL THIS
HAS WORKED OUT WE DID HAVE SOME
CASES LAST YEAR BUT SINCE THEN
WE HAVEN'T BEEN. GIVEN HOW.
TRANSMISSIBLE THIS VIRUS IS WE
ARE. WERE CLEARLY DOING THIS
RIGHT. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE TO MAINTAIN PROPER
MASK USAGE AT ALL TIMES PLEASE
DO NOT REMOVE OR LOWER YOUR
MASK WHEN SPEAKING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION.
TODAY IN FORTY TWO OH TWO WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF UNDELIVERED
THAT LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACEY. UP
THERE IS SPACE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM- THEY'RE ALSO
DISTRICT- DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITOL. FOR THEM
THIS YEAR IN THE ROOM. ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HANDS I WILL ASKYOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC COULD NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU HAVE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
RECENTLY WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
DISRUPTIONS RESULTING IN
INCIDENTS IN LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS. ANY CONDUCT THAT
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT THE HEARING
THIS ARE PROHIBITED. AND I WILL-WARN ONCE AND THEN IF YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE I'LL ASK THE OPERATOR
TO DISCONNECT YOU- IF YOU ARE-
DISRUPTING AND- THERE ARE
STRICT RULES ON WHAT YOU CAN
SAY ON THE PHONE WE'LL GET INTO
THOSE AS WE ASK FOR TESTIMONY.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE ALSO HAVE THE OPTION OF
TESTIFYING IN OUR WITNESS.
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM WHICH
IS LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL
IF YOU WANT TO USE THAT ROOM.
TO SPEAK UP IN THE SYSTEM WILL
COME ON AUTOMATICALLY. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATE PHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE. THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO LET ME REPEAT THESE
THE CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE IN ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLANNED IT TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHORED THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. ALL PHONE
TESTIMONY WILL BE TAKEN
TOGETHER AFTER BOTH SIDES
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE
PRESENTED. IF YOU WERE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE- THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICE
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
HE'S ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST BILL.
YOUR MAIN A LIFELINE I WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF INTO YOUR
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE
SIX FIVE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND I DO READ THOSE
LETTERS AS THEY COME IN. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH THIS IS WE
IMPLEMENT MESSAGE TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. CIMBER
MA'AM MEMBER HOLDEN WILL BE
ABSENT TODAY WE'RE PLEASED TO
HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
JOINED US. AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR
THE DAY AND HE HAS BEEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE MANY TIMES PRESENTING
GOOD BILLS SO WE'RE GLAD TO
HAVE HIM THANK YOU. SEVEN BILLS
WILL BE HEARD ONE IS PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT. IN FAIRNESS TO
EVERYONE WILL NEED TO BE
ESPECIALLY STRICT ON THE TIME
LIMITS NOTHER COMMITTEE WILL BE
USING THIS ROOM AFTER US THIS
AFTERNOON. TESTIMONY IS LIMITED
TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH
SIDE PER BALE. AFTER THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY I WILL
FIRST ASK FOR SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM. I WILL DO THE SAME
FOR THE OPPOSITION AGAIN PLEASE
NOTE THAT FROM TESTIMONY WILL
BE COMBINED. FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WE TAKEN AFTER
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED. AND WILL BE LIMITED
TO TWENTY MINUTES OF PHONE
TESTIMONY PER BILL SO GET IN
THE QUEUE QUICKLY. ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESS WILL BE
LIMITED. TO OUR POLICE STATE
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION IF THEY
RESET AND IF THEY REPRESENT ONE
IN A POSITION ON THE BILL THANK
YOU. SO QUORUM IS PRESENT. WILL
MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- THERE IS ONE DETAIL
WHICH IS- YG STATE BILL. SO
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IT'S HAS ONE ITEM IT'S AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT CORK. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WORK HI THANK YOU-
SMITH ALL RIGHT. HI CORK ICE
SMITH I ARAMBULA. BARRICADE
HANDS DALLY. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI LOU BLOOM I
MATHIS ALL RIGHT. MATHIS I WHAT
A TO G. WE HAVE. FIVE SO
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. BY COINCIDENCE
MISTER BLOOM IS ALSO HERE TO
PRESENT A BILL. AND I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE HERE SO PLEASE
MISTER BLOOM IT'S TIME. THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR FRESHWATER SITES ARE
SAFE FOR RECREATION PLEASE WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS. YEAH
YEAH REAL LIFE AND HAVING A DAY
AND A DAY OR NIGHT BEING HERE
I'D LIKE TO THAT YOU'RE NUMBER
YOUR ABILITY AND BEEN WORKING
MY OFFICE FARM. TO BE PUBLICLY
SHARED UNLIKE COASTAL WATERS
CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS LAKES AND
STREAMS ARE NOT MONITORED FOR
RECREATIONAL WATER QUALITY IN
THE SAME MANNER AS OCEAN
BEACHES IN ADDITION THE SMALL
AMOUNT OF DATA AND MONITORING
THAT IS DONE IS MOST OFTEN NOT
CURRENT OR READILY AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. BECAUSE RIVERS
LAKES AND STREAMS NOT BEING
ROUTINELY MONITORED. THOUSANDS
OF VISITORS TO FRESH WATER
RECREATION. SITES MAY BE
EXPOSED TO CONTAMINATED WATER
WITH NO KNOWLEDGE OF ITS
CONTAMINATION THIS WAS THE
SITUATION THAT EXISTED AND
CALIFORNIA BEACHES FOR MANY
YEARS UNTIL WE BEGAN TESTING OF
AND MUCH IN THE WAY THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING HERE. RATHER THAN
ATTEMPT TO A TO ESTABLISH AN
STATUTE WHICH SITES NEED TO BE
TESTED AB TEN SIXTY SIX
REQUIRES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
WATER QUALITY MONITORING
COUNCIL. IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC TO
PROPOSE TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD A DEFINITION OF A
MONITORED FRESH WATER
RECREATION SITE ORDER BEFORE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AB TEN SIXTY SIX IS
MODELED AFTER AB FOUR ONE ONE
WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW WAY
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
AND ESTABLISHED REQUIREMENTS
FIRST REGULAR STATE AND LOCAL
MONITORING OF COASTAL WATERS.
AND INFORM THE PUBLIC WHEN THE
WATERS POSED A HEALTH HAZARD.
THIS IS NOT A COSTLY NEW STATE
PROGRAM- IT WHAT IT DOES IS
BUILT ON WORK THAT'S ALREADY BE
DONE BEING DONE BY THE US W. R.
C. B. AND MANY PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR FRESH WATER
RECREATION SITE MANAGERS. BY
IMPROVING GREATER CONSISTENCY
AND TRANSPARENCY TO FRESH WATER
IN WATER QUALITY TESTING. THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE CONSISTENT
TESTING PROTOCOLS AND
METHODOLOGIES WE WANT TO
CORRECT THAT. AB TEN SIXTY SIX
FIXES KEY ELEMENTS OF THIS
HEALTH PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING
UNIFORM MONITORING STANDARDS
WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING AN EQUITY
ISSUE. INLAND AREAS SHOULD BE
AFFORDED THE SAME PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS AS COASTAL AREAS.
NOT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
LUXURY OF LIVING BY OR EVEN
VISITING THE COAST AND MANY OF
THOSE RESIDENTS RELY ON FRESH
WATER BODIES LIKE LAKES RIVERS
AND STREAMS. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
AB TEN SIXTY SIX US- THE STAFF
REPORT INDICATES IT IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS. AND IS ONLY THE
FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE. MY STAFF AND I AS WELL
AS A SPONSOR OF THE BILL ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE COUNCIL THE WATER
BOARD AND PRIVATE OWNER
OPERATORS TO ENSURE THIS
LEGISLATION IS BOTH FAIR AND
EFFECTIVE. AB TEN SIXTY SIX
WILL ADDRESS A KEY PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGE THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS FACE AN OUTDOOR
RECREATION ENSURING THERE ARE
SCIENCE AND HEALTH BASED
BACTERIAL STANDARDS ONGOING
WATER QUALITY MONITORING AND
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION FOR FRESH
WATER RECREATION. WHERE NEEDED.
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE IS A
MAGNIFICENT STATE AND ONE THAT
AFFORDS ALL OUR COMMUNITIES
WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECREATION OUTDOORS WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL ALL OF US FOR THAT.
THOSE THAT ENJOY OUR LAKES
RIVERS AND STREAMS DESERVE THE
SAME ASSURANCES THAT THE
FRESHWATER SITES ARE SAFE TO
SWIM AND JUST AS THOSE WHO
ENJOY OUR COASTAL BEACHES.
CALLING IN TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE DOCTOR
SURE SHELLEY LOOSE PRESIDENT
AND CEO FEEL THE BAG AND ANALLY
SIMO OF OUR WATER LA COALITION-
AGAIN YOUR FIRST DAY OF THE
HEAD OF HIM TODAY YES ACTUALLY
LOOSE YES ALL RIGHT- SHELTON SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FOUR MINUTES
TOTAL OF TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES
EACH SHORT DIVIDED UP ANOTHER
WAY AND THEN- MICHELI LOOSE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GO FIRST. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIR QUIRK AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR SHELLEY
LOOSE AND THEN PRESIDENT OF THE
OF THE BANK AND WE ARE
SPONSORING AB TEN SIXTY SIX
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF FOR HEARING THIS BILL AND
WORKING WITH US ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THEY LED THE
EFFORT OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO TO GET BASIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS FOR OCEAN BEACH
GOERS AND THANKS TO A BEFORE
ELEVEN VISITORS TO OVER FIVE
HUNDRED OF CALIFORNIA'S BELOVED
BEACHES ARE BETTER PROTECTED
BECAUSE THEY ARE INFORMED.
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF FECAL
POLLUTION IN THE WATER WHICH
COULD MAKE THEM SICK. INCREASED
AND STANDARDIZED MONITORING AT
OUR BEACHES HAS LED TO FURTHER
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS TO CLEAN
UP THE WATER AT OUR BEACHES.
AND FOR FURTHER PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND TOGETHER THIS
KEEPS PEOPLE SAFE- BUT TODAY
PEOPLE STILL GET SICK FROM
WATER CONTACTED BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS LAKES AND
STREAMS ARE NOT CONSISTENTLY
MONITORED FOR FECAL POLLUTION
LIKE OUR BEACHES OUR- DATA FROM
THE CDC AN ACADEMIC RESEARCHER
SHOW US THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA DO GET SICK.
FROM FRESHWATER RECREATION
EVERY SUMMER. WHAT AB CAN
SIXTIES PROPOSED. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAID IS NOT BRAND NEW
THE MAIN GOAL OF THE BILL IS TO
PROVIDE VISITORS TO OUR
FRESHWATER RECREATION AREA.
WITH THE INFORMATION THEY NEED.
TO MAKE THE CHOICE TO KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE AND HEALTHY.
THERE ARE ALREADY GROUPS AROUND
THE STATE COLLECTING AND
POSTING WATER QUALITY DATA. LOW
SPORADICALLY AND NOT
CONSISTENTLY THE STATE WATER
BOARD HAS RESOURCES DEDICATED
TO THESE MONITORING EFFORTS AND
MOST OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ALREADY IN PLACE FOR MONITORING
PROGRAM. SO WHAT WE NEED AND
BETTER COORDINATION BETTER
COVERAGE OF WHAT ABOUT A STATE
WIDE AND STANDARDIZATION ACROSS
OF MONITORING PROGRAMS. SOCIAL
THE BAY WILL WORK WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM THE STATE
WATER BOARD AND THE MONITORING
COUNCIL TO ADDRESS REMAINING
QUESTIONS RAISED IN BILL
ANALYSIS AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR THAT
THOUGHTFUL AND INSIGHTFUL
ANALYSIS. TO ENSURE THAT WE END
UP WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE BILL
FOR AB TEN SIXTY SIX AT THE
FIRST STEP TOWARDS PROTECTING
ALL CALIFORNIANS FROM. THE
START THE NEXT STEP TOWARD
PROTECTING ALL CALIFORNIANS
FROM FECAL POLLUTION AT THEIR
FAVORITE SWIMMING HOLE. AND WE
HOPE WILL INSPIRE EVEN MORE
HEALTH PROTECTION IN THE
FUTURE- AT THE SCENE AT OUR
OCEAN BEACHES. WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE YESTERDAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THANK YOU AND THEN- AT
LEAST TOMORROW- YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED.
TRANSACTION GOOD MORNING CHECK
WORKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ALEX AND I AM SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE OUR WATER LAKE
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SIXTY SIX OUR WATER LA AS A
DIVERSE COALITION AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND ORGANIZATIONS FROM
ACROSS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
UNITED TO CREATE A STRONG WATER
FUTURE FOR LOS ANGELES. I IS TO
FIX IT CLEAN SAFE FOR AND
RELIABLE WATER FOR ALL THE ALL
THE WAYS THAT WE LIVE. WORK AND
USE WATER NOW AND FOR THE
FUTURE. THERE ARE CURRENTLY A
PUBLIC HEALTH DISPARITY IN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED TO OCEAN BEACH GOERS
AND THOSE ACCORDED TO VISITORS
ABOUT THEIR. STREAMS AND MAKE.
A BEACH. WITH AB WITHIN A
CERTAIN THEM AT OCEAN BEACH AS
ITS NUMBER. WITH A MEMBER OF
THE AND- TO STORM DURING THAT I
REGULAR. I THE WATERS FOR BACK
TO POLLUTION. I AS PUBLIC NOTED
THAT OF THE WATER CALL. OKAY
SHOULDN'T LIVE NEAR THE COAST
OR FOR HIM BECAUSE HIS EASILY
THE- AND THEN PRESS WATER.
PROVIDE A SENSE RECREATIONAL
LIKE WOMEN WAITING BACK AND
OTHER OF WHAT CONTACT
RECREATION. CALIFORNIA USING
WATER WAYS BE THAT PROTECT AS
BEACH COLOR AGAIN. WE WORRIED
THAT BECAUSE LACK OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INCOME MADE A PART AND-
AMERICAN COLLEGES THAT PLAY IN
MAKE MEMBERS AND STREAMS. THESE
ARE THE SAME COMMUNITY CONSIDER
BE ON THE FOR LINES OF THE
CLINIC. MEETING THAT THEY WILL
BE IN THE BY AFFECTED CLIMATE
SUCH AS. TEN MANY OF MY
COMMUNITY L. A. COUNTY SEPARATE
FROM OF GREEN. AND READY TO IS.
VERY VACANCY. ARE VITAL THAT
THEY CAN CALL AND PHONE BILLS
BE COMING. IMPORTANT I SPENT
LIKE MY COMMUNITY BRENT AT THE
KIND EMERGENCY. AB TEN FEDERAL
CREDIT CARD PUBLIC HEALTH CREEK.
THE- TELL. THAT THEY'RE- THEIR
FAVORITE BEACHES FOR THAT. I
WATER LATE STRONG SUPPORTS
BEACON TO SIX- G. TO THE I
THANK YOU YOUR TIME AND UP TO
SPEAK MY. THANK YOU THAT WAS
PERFECT TIMING. ALL RIGHT- IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WANTS
TO TEST IN SUPPORT- IS THERE
ANYWAY IN THE OFFICE IN THE
ROOM ONCE TALK AND- IS THERE
ANY. ON THE VIDEO LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. RIGHT PHONE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB.
TEN SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TEN
SIXTY SIX AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
PLEASE ONLY QUEUE UP FOR
SUPPORT ONLY ON AB. TEN SIXTY
SIX. AND. OUR FIRST PERSONAL B.
LINE TWENTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWENTY EIGHT OCTOBER.
FRAZIER MEMBERS APPOINTED ALSO
ZERO CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MOVING ON WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CAITLYN
COOLEY WELL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COULD KEEPER ALLIANCE ALONGSIDE
TEN LOCAL WATERKEEPER
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT DEADLINE
FIFTEEN. ACCORDING TO CHEN
MEMBERS JUSTIN MALONE ON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE'VE ALSO BEEN US TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT OF SEVENTH
GENERATION ADVISES AND
ACTIVISTS SAN GABRIEL VALLEY WE
WHICH I VOTE THANK YOU. AND AS
SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- LET'S SEE SO THE NEXT
PART IS COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
YES MR VICE CHAIR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM ALIKE WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO GO WITH THIS BUT IT'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE RESTRICTIVE
THAN THE OCEANS BUT IN MY
DISTRICT I HAVE A LOT OF SKI
LAKES RECREATIONAL LAKES AND
THE NUMBERS ARE THOUSAND BUT IF
THEY DO ONE EVENT IT TRIGGERS A
TESTING FOR SIX MONTHS SO I
THINK IT WILL BE AN ADDED COST
TO A LOT OF PRIVATE LITTLE
INDUSTRIES SAW HEAD OF STATE
OPPOSED RIGHT NOW I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU. TO
TRY TO CHANGE THAT MAKE IT WORK
BETTER FOR ALL MY DISTRICT
THANK YOU. YOUR ON. THAT IS A
VERY CLEAR POSITION THANK YOU-
I WOULD ASK- THAT WE TAKE UP
COST PER SE NOW YOU'RE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT POLICY YOU WANT
THAT CHANGED BUT COST PER SE IS
DONE AND APPROPRIATIONS. SO IF
YOU HAVE A MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM DOESN'T MATTER TOO MUCH
HERE BUT IT WILL IN
APPROPRIATIONS- SO KNOW WHETHER
COMMENTS OKAY SO- YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER BLOOM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
CERTAINLY- OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE- IS SO WE HAVE A REQUEST
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO- ACTUALLY
DO BUT IF YOU CAN WORK WITH THE
WATER BOARD TO CONSOLIDATE. OUR
PROGRAMS- TO GIVE THEM A LITTLE
MORE LOGICAL YOU KNOW WE HAD ON
ONE BILL AT THE TIME AND IT
GETS DIFFICULT FOR THE
COMMITTEE SO IF THE IF FOR THE
WATER BOARD SO IF THE WATER
BOARD WILL WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO
SEE THAT AND THEN THERE'S A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS HERE ON
PAGE EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS AND
I KNOW YOU'LL BE WORKING ON
THOSE CORRECT ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE- AND LET
ME SAY COMMITTEE STAFF AND I
WILL. YOU KNOW WILL BE THERE
FOR YOU EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
SO JUST LET US KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND- WE WILL WE WILL
HELP YOU ANY WAY WE CAN THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT GOOD AND
SHOW MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS- WE-
MOTION IT HAS BEEN MOTIONED AND
SECONDED JUST CONFIRMING THAT-
ITEM NUMBER ONE. THIS IS AB TEN
SIXTY SIX BLOOM THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CORK. I WORK AYE SMITH. SMITH
NO ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN. DALLY
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI. BLOOM HI BLOOM HI MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MURATSUCHI
OKAY SO WE'LL PUT THAT. OKAY SO
WE NEED TO MARK THANK YOU YES-
I WAS TOLD THAT- REBECCA BAUER
K. HAND- WILL BE HERE A BIT
LATE- SO MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE- IF THE-
SERGEANTS CAN NOTE THAT MR
LEVINE IS NEXT UP IN OUR WATER
AND HOPEFULLY HE WILL GET HERE
IN THE NEXT FIVE TO TEN MINUTES.
ALL RIGHT THIS IS ABOUT THE
VERY THIS IS A B. SEVEN FIVE
THREE ABOUT UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANK CLEANUP TRUST FUND OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
BROWNFIELD'S REMEDIATION AND
REDEVELOPMENT AND IT. SECOND
WAS ABOUT TO SAY IT'S SUCH AN
EXCELLENT BILL. ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT YEAH MISTER GRAY PLAY
PRESENT. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE
WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP FUND AND CREATES A TASK
FORCE THAT WILL STUDY EXPANDING
ELIGIBLE USES OF THE FUND TO
INCLUDE BROWNFIELD REMEDIATION
FOR HOUSING. THE UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANK CLEANUP ON WAS
CREATED AS A FREE PROGRAM OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO AND HAS BEEN
EXTENDED NUMEROUS TIMES SINCE
ITS CREATION IT IS BECOME ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WATER SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA. AB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE DOES NOT
CREATE A NEW TAX OR FEE IT
MERELY EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF
THIS INCREDIBLE RESOURCE AND
EXPLORES A PATHWAY TOWARD
REMEDIATING BROWNFIELD SITES IN
JOB IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS
CALIFORNIA HAS A MASSIVE
HOUSING SHORTAGE HOUSING IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN URBAN
AREAS ESPECIALLY NEAR JOBS AND
TRANSIT. HOWEVER BILLABLE URBAN
INFILL LAND IS OFTEN PASSED
OVER DUE TO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FROM PREVIOUS
DEVELOPMENT THESE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES TAKE UP VALUABLE
LAND IN AREAS WHERE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS NEEDED THE MOST
THE FIRM REIMBURSES UNDERGROUN
STORAGE TANK OWNERS FOR COST
FROM CLEANING UP FUEL TANKS IT
ALSO FUNDS PROJECTS THAT CLEAN
UP ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION
FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES
INCLUDING ON BROWNFIELD
PROPERTIES. THANKS TO THE
EFFORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
REDUCE SUCH BELIEFS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION
THERE ARE FAR FEWER NEW
APPLICANTS TO THE FUND THAN
EVER BEFORE WHICH PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING TO CLEAN UP PROPERTIES
ON WHICH HOUSING CAN BE BUILT
AB SEVEN FIFTY THREE MILLION
EXTENSIVE SUNSET OF THIS FUN
AND CREATES A STAKEHOLDER TASK
FORCE TO STUDY THE PRIORITIZING
FUNDING TO CLEAN UP. PROPERTIES
THAT WILL SERVE HOUSING
PURPOSES IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS
THIS WILL SUPPORT THE STATE'S
GOALS OF REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS AND BUILDING URBAN
HOUSING MY WITNESSES ARE
BRADFORD PRACTITIONER MARCUS
THE BANK AND IT DOES SHOW THEY
READ OR READ. WHICH WITH THIS
FOR LAMPREYS. VERY GOOD CHAU-
EGNATIA- DIREST ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE FOR CREATIVE LANDON
RECYCLING- YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY- WHEN YOU HAVE
TOO MANY YES GOOD MORNING. I
HAVE YES GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
ALL I'M THE PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR DISINTEGRATED NINETY
CYCLING FORESEE CLEAR FOR SHORT
IT'S THE ONLY NATIONAL
NONPROFIT DEDICATED. TO
SUSTAINABLE VALUES OF UNDER
UTILIZED PROPERTIES. SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE SEE
CLEAR EXCEPT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES RAISED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN BROWNFIELDS GRANTS
FROM THE U. S. E. P. H. BEFORE
SHE CLEAR. I WAS I WAS THE
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT MANAGER
WITH THE CITY OF AND REBUILD
DURING WORK FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS AND COLLABORATED WITH
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
UNSUSTAINABLE REVIEWS. AROUND
THE- FOR YOU SITE THE FIFTH
THINKING FUNDS I ALSO BILL
COMING I CALL ON THE BOOK OUT
THIS YEAR. NOW THAN EVER
FUNDING FOR DOING AND CLEAN UP
THE SCRIPT TO PASS. CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT GOALS AND HOUSING
NEEDS SINCE THE LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT FIFTIES
ESSENTIALLY LOST THEIR ONLY
LOCAL SOURCE FUNDS. ASSESSMENT
AND CLEANUP THE RECENT
IMPROVEMENTS A TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS DO NOT OFFSET
THIS LOSS BECAUSE SCHOOLS LIKE
THE ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS. AND THE
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION
INVESTMENT ACTS ARE USED MAINLY
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUBLIC
IMPROVEMENTS HOUSING PROPONENTS
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH FUNDS
TO ASSESS AND CLEAN UP. THAT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF SITE THAT
WILL BE NEEDED FOR INPUT
HOUSING. EVEN USING MODEST
COKES COSTS SHIKIAR ESTIMATE
THAT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY ARE NEEDED TO
KEEP UP WITH THE STATE INFILL
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT NEEDS. WITH
THIS MONEY THAT CITY NONPROFITS
IN HOUSING DEVELOPERS SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE. APART FROM VERY
COMPETITIVE GRANTS AVAILABLE
FROM THE EPA AND KALECKI PA
THERE ARE FEW SOURCES INITIATE
AND PURSUE DEVELOPMENT THE
VACANT UNDERUTILIZED. OR
BLIGHTED INFILL PROPERTIES AB
SEVENTY TWO THREE WILL PROVIDE.
FUNDS TO STUDY THIS NEED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER DE- WE
HAVE MARK NEED BANK BROWN
FILLED PRACTITIONER ON THE
PHONE. PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIFTY THREE. I. MARKET'S NEW
BANK AT THE END OF OUR MIDDLE
PRACTITIONERS CALIFORNIA FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. THE DOG
SENDS THE SUNSET DATE OF THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK
CLEANUP ON THEN CREATES A GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO STUDY THE
EXPANSION OF THE FUND'S MISSION.
OKAY CLEAN UP OF POCATELLO IN
AND NONCONTROLLING. IN SUPPORT
OF INFILL HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
THE PRESERVATION OF HUMAN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. AS WELL
AS THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIANS DRINKING WATER
QUALITY. THIS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AS A MECHANISM TO
ALLOW OWNERS AND OPERATORS OF
UNDERGROUND TANKS TO SATISFY ME
FEDERAL CLIMATE OF FINANCIAL
ASSURANCE. THE DEMONSTRATION OF
SUFFICIENT FINANCIAL RESERVES
TO RESPOND BY MAIL IMPACT
CAUSED BY A WOULD BE. FROM A
TANK SYSTEM. THE CLEAN UP
UNSERVED PURPOSE AND PRUITT'S
REIMBURSE OF COSTS SO WITH
CLEANUP ACCOMPLISHED MORE IN
TERMS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION WATER SUPPLY
PROTECTION THAN ANY OTHER
CURRENT OR PRIOR STATE OR
FEDERAL PROGRAM. ONE NEED ONLY
LOOK TO THE AND TO BE CRISIS OF
THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES SPOT
FOR THE CLEANUP PROGRAM THERE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO AGGRESSIVELY
RESPOND THAT UNEXPECTED
GASOLINE. ADDITIVE WATER
QUALITY. RISE A FEW YEARS BACK
UP ACCOUNT WAS CREATED TO
MANAGE UP OF THE FUND THE MODEM
IT'S NOT PROPERTY BY NOT AND-
REPUBLICAN. CLAIMS HAD LEFT ON.
THE PROGRAM IS QUITE PRESENTLY
PLANNED UNTIL AT THE END OF
TWENTY FIVE AND BY THEIR
METRICS THE PROGRAM EXPECT BY
THAT TIME COULD PAID ALL
OUTSTANDING CLAIMS. THE SUB
ACCOUNT FOR NON PATROL
INCREDIBLE SUNSET THAT AT THAT
TIME AS WELL. IT'S NOW CLEAR
THAT THE CALIFORNIA TRANSITION
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS GOING
TO OCCUR QUICKLY. A MISSILE
MOTIVATED TRANSITION OF
THOUSANDS IF NOT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PETROLEUM
INFASTRUCTURE PROPERTIES. IN
ON PETROLEUM USES AN EXTENSION
OF THE FUND IN ANTICIPATION OF
THE THOUSANDS OF TANKS THAT
WILL BE REMOVED IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS IS NEEDED THAT SELF. A
RECONFIGURE OF THE FUND.
CLEANUP AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION IN OTHER STATES THIS
FEELS VERY POSSIBLE AS WELL
ESPECIALLY AT THIS. CRITICAL
TIME IN CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT
TO THE NEEDS FOR HOUSING IF YOU
COULD BOTTLE APPLICATION UPON
FINISH UP. I'M SORRY PLEASE
FINANCIAL ALMOST UP. YEP LEAVE
NOTED THAT PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES
WOULD BE WHICH BY ITSELF WOULD
NOT BE A GOOD IDEA THIS BILL
PROPOSES A STUDY BOTH- AND- THE
STUDY GROUP TO CONSIDER THAT WE
CONFIGURATION OF THE-
IMPORTANCE OF YOUR C. PROGRAM-
PIETISTIC. AND PARTICIPANTS
THANKS AGAIN AND I'M SORRY I
WAS LONG WINDED. SHE ALL RIGHT.
SO NOW WE WILL FOR ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
AND I SEE NO ONE. ARM AND THEN
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK ON
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. JUST
SPEAK UP AND THE SYSTEM TURNS
ON AND WE DON'T SEE ANYONE SO
NEXT PHONE MODERATOR DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVEN FIVE THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON AB
SEVEN FIVE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AN OPERATOR'S GONNA GIVE
YOU YOUR LIFE NUMBER OFFLINE A
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE
SO AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. AND PLAN OUR FIRST PLEASE
JUST GIVE NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ONLY THANK YOU. I
HAD THANK YOU. YEAH YEP IT WILL
GO TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RICO
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL BIRCHER I BOOKED. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN AND AS
A REMINDER TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION ON AB SEVEN FIVE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD FIFTY.
YOUR MEMBERS JUSTIN MALONE ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
YELLOW PEAS THE LOCAL CLEAN UP
AGENTS. VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT MISS GRAYSON PLEASE CLOSE
THANK YOU DON'T WAIT I'M SORRY
I FORGOT. MY APOLOGIES MY
APOLOGIES DI<c.cyan> THANK YOU</c>
MISTER CHAIR- MISTRESS I DO
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE WITH THIS- I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME LIGHT
OPPOSITION ON THE LETTER AND I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THEM- I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO- IF YOU
GUYS CAN COME TO A- GOOD
CONCLUSION ON THAT THAT'LL OPEN
UP THAT'LL INSURE THAT- THE
EXISTING PLANS AN- INDUCTION A
REAL ISSUE WOULD PUT IT- STAY
THERE. I'D BE WILLING TO COME
ON AS A CO AUTHOR WITH YOU ON
THIS BILL- I WILL GIVE YOU A
YESTERDAY AND LET ME KNOW HOW
THOSE CONVERSATIONS GO CLOSELY
CONNECTED FARTHER OUT
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS. ORDER ALL
RIGHT. WILL THEN GO AHEAD WITH
WITH COLORS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
OFFICE IS WORKING WITH
CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE- TO
ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE AND CONFIDENT WE CAN GET
THERE- WITH THAT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- CONSIDERATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ADVICE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD EXTENDING THE-
FUND IS VERY IMPORTANT- I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED A LOT
MORE MONEY IN THE FUND- WE'LL
SEE HOW AND WHICH IS REALLY
WHAT THIS- CONCERN IS BALLOT-
WE WILL SEE WHAT WE CAN DO OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS- CHAU.
WE'VE ALREADY HAD A MOTION AND
A SECOND. AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL- I'M RECOMMENDED
AYE VOTE AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SEVEN FIFTY
THREE GRAYSON THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. WORK I
CORK HI SMITH. SMITH NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN. DALLY
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I BLOOM BLOOM I MATHIS MATHIS I
WOULD HAVE TO G. SO THAT HAS
FOUR VOTES WE NEED TO PUT IT.
FOR LATER THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON. MR
LEVINE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
ON TIME. THE BILL. OKAY SO THIS
IS ABOUT HAZARDOUS WASTE A. B.
THREE ONE EIGHT AND WHAT DO WE
DO WITH ORGANIC WASTE WHICH IS
A VERY TOUGH PROBLEM- WHEN
WE'RE DEALING WITH. NEW
MATERIALS WE HAVEN'T HAD IN
ABUNDANCE BEFORE THANK YOU GO
AHEAD MISTER CHAIR I THINK YOU
JUST GAVE MY PRESENTATION HAHA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WORKS FOR ME- DO YOU HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I DO I
HAVE- NICK CRANE- NUMBER THE
COOPER FORM BOARD AND EDDIE
FRANCO THE LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY AFFAIRS MANAGER THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND ANY FRANCO IS
AN ALUMNI OF MY OFFICE SO FOR
THAT I AM GRATEFUL TO HAVE HIM-
STUNNING PEDIGREE CERNEY YES.
ALL RIGHT PHONE MODERATOR-
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE- NICHOLAS
CRANE ON BEHALF OF THE
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCY FORUM BOARD. PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S NICK CRANE MY JOB
TITLES- PROGRAM CHEAPER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARDS
MITCHELL MANAGEMENT BRANCH THE
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCY OR COOPER. RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I AM A GROUP OF ONE
BOARD MEMBER WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER A HUNDRED AND UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I'M ALSO THE BOARD'S
LEAD HAZARDS WE FISHING
COORDINATOR AS N THIS CAPACITY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THREE EIGHTEEN
TODAY. I HAVE OVER SIXTEEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE MANAGING
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND CURRENTLY
MANAGEMENT MERGER SPOTS TEAM
AND HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY THE ISSUE ABOUT CANNABIS
PLANT WASTES AND OTHER
GREENWAYS HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
BE HANDLED AS HAZARDOUS. WASTE
DURING THESE CLEAN UP
OPERATIONS. IT WAS RATHER STATE
RIGHT THOU OF BILLS. THAT YOU
HAS WASTE DAY. THESE BENEFITS
RIGHT IN SIZE FROM SMALL. SUCH
AS OUR SHOP CONTRACT TO LARGER
BUSINESS INVOLVED WITH METAL
PLATING MANUFACTURING. DUE TO
THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
CANNABIS FACILITIES WERE ADDED
TO THE REGULAR DISTALLY LET'S
BEGINNING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUT HOW TO SWITCH THE GENERATOR.
UNFORTUNATELY DECIDE EXPECTED
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATED THESE
CAMPUS FACILITIES SUCH AS WHICH
PESTICIDES. MORE CANNABIS
ITSELF THE BASIC PLAN TRAM AND
CANNABIS CONTAINING PRODUCTS
SUCH AS OILS DERIVED FROM A
PLANT. SALE THE QUADCOPTER CITY
CRITERIA OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
FISH BILE ACID. SOMETHING
UNKNOWN IN CANNABIS KILLS FISH.
THIS WASN'T TERRIBLY SURPRISING
AS IT HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR YEARS
THE NUMEROUS CROPS AND PLANTS
FEEL THE FISHBAR ESTATE SUCH AS
BLACK TEA EUCALYPTUS MEDO
ENABLING AND- MY VIRTUE OF
STATUTE OF THOSE CROPS IN PLAN
BEEN MANAGE ADDRESS. NO NOR
SHOULD IT BE CANNABIS IS NO
DIFFERENT. AB THREE CAME
PREVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE EXCLUDED
ORGANIC OR GREEN WASTE FROM
BEING MANAGES HAS MISPLACED. WE
WILL NOW REQUIRE GUIDELINES FOR
WHAT IS ALREADY IN PRACTICE THE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE WHICH
STREAM THROUGH OTHER LEGAL
MEANS BUT NOT WE ADDRESS WHICH
MANAGEMENT. IT IS NONSENSICAL
DEMANDS CROPS GROWN FOR FOOD OR
MEDICINE AS HAZARDOUS WASTE
INCREASE IN PRODUCER COSTS WITH
STRICTER DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS FOR WE STREAM
WHICH CAN BE SAFELY MANAGED AT
LOWER COST AND GREATER IN FROM
ABOUT THAT. WE DON'T NEED OR
WANT ORGANIC WASTE THAT WE
ROUTINELY CONSUME FILLING UP
OUR HOUSES WHICH LANDFILLS.
PASSING AB THREE EIGHTEEN WILL
RECALL. FURTHER GUIDELINE FROM
EACH WHICH- WILL. LOW
AUTHORITIES DON'T NEARLY
RESOURCE ON OUR- HOUSES WE CAN
FORCE. REDUCE COSTS RELIGION
BUSINESSES THE STATE AND PUT
INTO LAW WAS ALREADY IN
PRACTICE IN EVERY LOCAL- BUT
ACROSS THE STATE. WE WORK WITH
OFFICE OFFCE INDUSTRY AND YOU
CAN SEE ON AMENDMENTS. AND THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE WILL CREATE A
PATHWAY TO FURTHER ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS IN DEVELOPING
GUIDELINES THAT CAN COMPLEMENT
EXISTING LAW. THEREFORE I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB TREATING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU SIR. AND THE NEXT IS MY
FRIEND AB FRANCO. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ATTY FRANCO
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH MECHANICAL
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO BE ATTRACT YOU MISTER CHAIR
I USED TO THE WAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL DPF THE DETERMINES HOW
I TYPE OF WEIGHT HOW TO GET TO
ENVIRONMENT ADVOCATE CRANE JUST
MENTIONED GREEN WASTE OR
ORGANIC WASTE SUCH AS LEAVES.
WE NEED BRANCHES OTHER NON
HARMFUL BY AMERICA IS
CONSIDERED HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
UNDER STATE LAW IT INCLUDES
WASTE PRODUCED BY THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AS A RESULT OF THIS
CLASSIFICATION COMPOST FACILITY
THAN OTHER WAYS REGULATE YOUR
OPERATIONS ARE UNABLE TO ACCEPT
GREEN ORGANIC WASTE FROM
CANNABIS OPERATE OPERATORS DID
NOT ONLY LEAD TO INCREASED
OPERATIONAL COSTS FOR CANNABIS
OPERATORS. WHO MUST CONTRACTORS
HAD NOT OPERATIONS TO PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF THIS PLANT WAIT IT
CURRIED USE DETAIN ABILITY IN
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN SO BY
DIRECTING THE PTSD TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND DISPOSAL OF THE
GREEN ORGANIC WASTE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THAT CDFA AND
POWER CYCLE THIS BILL OFFERS A
PATHWAY FOR NON HARMFUL
CANNABIS WAIT TO BE COMPOSTED
OR OTHERWISE RESPONSIBLY
DISPOSE- I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND THE
BILL'S SPONSORS FOR THEIR
CONTINUE ON PROACTIVE OUTREACH
TO THE INDUSTRY. THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS AND THEIR
COMMITMENT TO BRINGING MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY TO
THE CANNABIS SUPPLY GENIUSES
THAT ISSUE THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN DISCUSSING I'D BREAK UP
FOR YEARS NOW SO EXCITED TO BE
HERE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE. ON
SO MUCH. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S SEE SO QUEST COMMENTS YES
FIRST MID VICE CHAIR. ASSEMBLY
LEVINE A LOOK FORWARD TO SOME
THIS BILL IT'S WHO HAVE THOUGHT
THAT GREEN WASTE WOULD BE WASTE
BUT WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO GET THROUGH TO GET
CLARIFICATIONS AND MY DISTRICT
I HAVE A BIG PROBLEM WITH THE
MARIJUANA INDUSTRY. THE LEGAL
SIDE OF IT NOT THE LEGAL SIDE
OF IT WE ALL KNOW THAT SIR BUT
I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT
AND IF YOU CONSIDER CO AUTHORS
I'D LOVE TO JOIN ON THAT BE
FANTASTIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SMITH I LEARNED A LOT.
ON THIS BILL TO. I FOR MISTER
MATHIS. WITH THAT I GUESS- I
RECOMMEND MY VOICE YOUR JUMP ON
AS A JOINT AUTHORS NO THEY'RE
LIKE LIKE I'D I'D I'D LIKE TO
BE I LIKE THE BILL I THINK IT'S
A- GREAT. IN ITS WELL NEEDED.
AND THE CLARIFICATION WITH
GREEN WASTE AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
IN THE SECTORS DEFINITELY. ARE
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
AND AS AS THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF
AGRICULTURE I REALLY RESPECT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE. AND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE INDUSTRY
MOVING FORWARD. THANKS THANK
YOU MR MATTHEW OUT WE- WE OFTEN
ASK BECAUSE AUTHORS BUT- WHEN
YOU'RE WHEN SOMEONE'S RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU IT'S BEST NOT TO
ASK TO BE A JOINT AUTHORS TO ST.
CO AUTHORS GREAT. YOU CAN
ALWAYS ASK LATER TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORS. YEAH I WELCOME THE
PILE ON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
LET'S SEE SO WE ARE NOW AT. ALL
RIGHT- IS THERE ANYONE ELSE YES
MISTER BLOOM I JUST WANNA SAY
THERE'S SOMETHING IRONIC ABOUT
THIS BILL BEING- HALFWAY
BETWEEN FOUR TWENTY AND FOR
TWENTY TWO. AND ALL THE CASTING
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ESTHER
BLOOM. YESTERDAY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE- MAY YOUR CLOTHES
PLEASE BRIEF IS YOUR INTRO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR STUFF OUT FOR NOW THOUGH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SIR WE
HAVE. NOW THIS IS OUR-
SOMETHING THAT WE AS THE
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS HAVE SAID
THAT WE JUST NEED TO GET
RESOLVED AND I'M VERY HAPPY YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD WE WILL BE
GLAD TO HELP IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT YOU NEED FROM US
AND JUST KEEP US INFORMED- AND
THEN I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THANK
YOU IT'S VERY GRACIOUS OF YOU.
MMHM. THAT IS RIGHT I SHOULD BE
A. I SHOULD LET THE FOR IT MR
ROM. YES SAYS MOVES- MR
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE ASK
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU- TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT- OUT AFTER- OPPOSITION
SKEWS ME ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
J. MEMBERS JUST MULLIN AGAIN
HERE FOR THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH DIRECTORS WE ARE
SPONSORING THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF THE COOPER FORM BOARD AND
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT IN
GETTING THOSE REGULATORY
CONUNDRUM SORT IT OUT. THANKS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
AS A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. BUT WE
DON'T WANT WORK. ADD MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. IS THERE A. LET'S SEE
WE'VE HEARD FROM MISTER CRANE
AND MR FRANCO IS IT DID WE HAVE
A PRIMARY OPPOSITION THE
PRIMARY PERSON IN OPPOSITION.
OH YES- JONATHAN LISICKI
ORDERED HALF A SPECIALIZED
SOLUTIONS INC PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING- OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS- AGAIN MY NAME'S JOHN
WILL CITY I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
SPECIALIZED WAY SOLUTIONS WE
SPECIALIZE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AND DISPOSAL OF
WASTE MATERIAL IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY- WHY WHY WE APPRECIATE
THAT THIS BILL NOW AS THE DTS
VEHICLE GUIDANCE- ARE WE STILL
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION TO THE
FACT THAT THE TNC HAS ALREADY
PUBLISHED A TECHNICAL REVIEW ON
APRIL TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY- TITLED REQUEST FOR YOU
TO GET THE EVALUATION OF ACUTE
NINETY SIX OUR BIO ESSAY ON
PROCESS CANNABIS PLANT MEDIA
WASTE. ANOTHER CROP WASTE. HI
THIS TECHNICAL REVIEW.
CONCLUDED THAT. THIS MEET YOUR
FAILED THE BIO AS- THEREFORE IS
HAZARDOUS INCIDENT. I'M NOT
WAITING TILL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. JUST KICKED THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD BY THE
INDUSTRY ENLIGHTENING
GENERATORS CONTINUE TO SHIPMENT
MATERIAL MUNICIPAL LANDFILLS.
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE EACH OF
UNIVERSITIES THAT TECHNICAL
PUBLICATION DATED FOUR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY BEFORE VOTING ON
THIS BILL. THIS BILL IS
OBSOLETE AS THE DATA ALREADY
EXISTS AND IS ONLY DELAYING
ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU. SHE I'M
I'M JUST ADD- IN MY COMMENTS
THAT THE FISH TEST IS A FISH
TEST. AND IT DOES NOT- INDICATE
THAT. HOW YOU SHOULD TREAT THE
WASTE ARM. I COULD GET INTO A
MORE DETAIL BUT I THINK IT'S
BEST THAT WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS WHOLE ISSUE AND THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BY MR ANYTHING. OKAY NOW WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
EIGHTEEN LEVINE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK HI QUIRK HI SMITH. SMITH
I. ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN. DELLY
DELLY I'D CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I BLOOM. BLOOM
I MATHIS MATHIS I WHAT A TO G.
MURATSUCHI I. WE HAVE AN EFFORT
TO HAVE SEVEN ALL RIGHT
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU SIR.
ALL RIGHT MISTER REAVIS PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND YOU MAY START
WHEN YOU'RE READY AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR ALL
THE TIME THAT WE'VE SPENT
WORKING TOGETHER- YOU'VE
LISTENED TO THE OPPOSITION ARE
AND EVEN THOUGH GROUPS REMAIN
OPPOSED IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF
EFFORT ON YOUR PART. SHE
PRESENT I JUST WANT TO ADD MY
OVERALL CONCERN IS THAT TO
MAINTAIN REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY
UP WITH THE STATE AND REGIONAL
WATER BOARDS WE BELIEVE WE'VE
ACHIEVED THAT THEY ARE NOT
QUITE SO SURE- WILL HAVE TO
WORK ON THAT AS WE GO FORWARD-
BUT I BELIEVE WE'RE VERY CLOSE.
SO PLEASE PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR THOSE. THOSE COMMENTS AND
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES- I WANT
TO THINK- AS YOU MENTIONED MR
CHAIRMAN I THINK- THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL OF- THE
CONSIDERATION THE WORK. THAT
WENT INTO- THIS BILL AND WHERE
IT'S AT NOW- AND I'M HERE TODAY
PRESENTS IN THE BILL THREE
SEVEN SEVENTY CALIFORNIA WATER
ACT WHEN THE- ORIGINAL CLEAN
WATER ACT PASSED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
THE GOAL OF THE ACT WAS TO
CLEAN UP OUR NATION'S WATERWAYS
BY THE MID NINETEEN EIGHTIES-
AND- I DIDN'T HAPPEN. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OVER 95% OF THE
SAYS WATERWAYS ARE STILL
IMPAIRED OR- POLLUTED ABOVE
WHAT WATER QUALITY STANDARDS
ALLOW. AND THAT'S ACCORDING TO
THE MOST RECENT WATER BOARD
SURVEY PUBLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND AS WE
ALL KNOW CLEAN WATER IS AN
ESSENTIAL ELEMENT OF A HEALTHY
AND PRODUCTIVE SOCIETY- WE SWIM
AND FISH IN THE WATERWAYS MANY
OF THEM SUPPLIER DRINKING WATER
AND ALL OF THEM SUPPORT OUR
DIVERSE ECOSYSTEM HERE. IN THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
EVERY AREA OF OUR STATE DEALS
WITH THE IMPACTS OF THESE
POLLUTANTS IN OUR LOCAL
WATERWAYS. EIGHT DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ARTICLE THE
L. A. TIMES HIGHLIGHTED HOW THE
LOS ANGELES AREA WON'T FULLY
CLEAN UP STORMWATER POLLUTION.
AND ACHIEVE IT'S- IT'S
COLLECTIVE CLEAN WATER GOAL
INTO THE TWENTY EIGHTIES.
TWENTY EIGHTIES AND THAT'S THE
BEST CASE SCENARIO. PART OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY NOW FACE SOME OF
THE HIGHEST WATER TREATMENT
COSTS IN THE STATE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE OR BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO GET
DRINKING WATER FROM THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER WHICH HAS SOME
POLLUTION WITH- TODAY JUST
LEVELS OF MERCURY. OR THEY CAN
CHOOSE TO GO TO NEARBY LAKES
AND RESERVOIRS THAT HIT THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE HAVE HAVE EVEN
STRONGER US SOME POLLUTANTS OF
MERCURY. THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
ALREADY LACK ACCESS TO RELIABLE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. IT IT'S A PROBLEM MADE
WORSE BY THIS POLLUTION YEAH ON
THE NORTH COAST TRIBAL CULTURAL
PRACTICES ARE BEING WIPED OUT
BECAUSE OF SEDIMENTATION IN
STREAMS. HAS DESTROYED SALMON
POPULATIONS. AND IN MY OWN
COUNTY SAN BENITO. THERE ARE
OVER A HUNDRED MILES OF RIVERS
AND STREAMS THAT ARE PAIRED
WITH E. COLI PESTICIDES HEAVY
METALS AND OTHER POLLUTANTS AND
THIS IS JUST IN ONE SMALL SMALL
COUNTY HERE IN OUR STATE. AND
DESPITE THESE GRIM EXAMPLES WE
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS- AS A
PROGRESS IMPROVING WATER
QUALITY SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE FEDERAL CLEAN WATER ACT.
FIFTY YEARS AGO- THERE WAS SO
MUCH RAW SEWAGE IN THE SENATE
IS KOBE. THAT IT LITERALLY
STANK. AND NOW AFTER MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN TREATMENT PLANTS
WATER QUALITY IS DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVED AND WHILE LIFE HAS
RETURNED TO THE BAY. AND
CLEARLY WE HAVE THE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY TO ACHIEVE CLEAN
WATER FOR ALL IN THIS STATE.
AND WE CAN DO IT WITHIN OUR
LIFETIMES. IF WE ACT NOW. SO
THIS BILL TE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
WATER ACT AIMS TO CHEAPLY WATER
IN OUR STATE BY TWENTY FIFTY.
AND TO DO SO IT HAS THREE PARTS
FIRST IT REQUIRES THE STATE AND
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO ACHIEVE
CLEAN WATER BY TWENTY FIFTY-
THIS PLANNING EXERCISE WILL
ALLOW THEM TO USE. ALL TOOLS AT
THEIR DISPOSAL TO FIND THE BEST
MOST COST EFFECTIVE PATHWAY TO
ACHIEVE CLEAN WATER. AND SECOND
IT REQUIRES THE WATER BOARDS TO
FOCUS ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS. ON
WORST VIOLATORS. IN THE MOST
IMPAIRED WATERWAYS. ENSURING
THAT WE'RE GETTING THE MOST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK ON THE
ENFORCEMENT FRONT. IT'LL ALSO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR WATER BOARDS
TO RECOVER THEIR ENFORCEMENT
COSTS AS A NUMBER OF OTHER
AGENCIES IN THE STATE ALREADY
DO. AND SO THAT DISCHARGERS WHO
ARE COMPLYING WITH THE LAW
DON'T HAVE TO SUBSIDIZE THE
COST. OF GOING AFTER BAD ACTORS.
IT'S ALL FINALLY THIS
LEGISLATION AB THREE SEVEN
SEVEN WILL RE ALLOCATE SOME
EXISTING MONEY AT THE WATER
BOARD WITHOUT RAISING NEW
REVENUES- TO PAY FOR
REMEDIATION OF THE MOST
IMPAIRED WATERWAYS HERE IN OUR
STATE. AND AS HAVE AS YOU HAVE
NO DOUBT NOTICED THIS BILL HAS
UNDERGONE SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD. I HAVE A
HAND OUT THAT I HAD TO DO TO
THE SECRETARY TO YELLOW PAGE-
WHERE IT SHOWS ALL THE
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE MADE AND
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
WE ARE COMPLETELY OPEN TO
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE
ENGAGED STAKEHOLDERS- IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. EVERY
STEP. OF THE WAY THE TO THIS
COMMITTEE- AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT'S WHERE THE OF
OUR DEBATE. WE SHOULD. ALL COME
TO THE NEGOTIATION TABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN FINALLY
CLEAN UP OUR WATERWAYS WHEN WE
READ IN THE L. A. TIMES AT.
SOME POLLUTION DUE TO
STORMWATER WILL BE CLEANED UP
AND TOP POSSIBLY TWENTY EIGHTY.
UNACCEPTABLE. AND SO THERE'S
MANY THINGS WE HAVE DONE IT YOU
KNOW- THAT WE'VE REMOVED A
PROHIBITION ON THE WATER
BOARD'S DEEMING IN COMPLIANCE
ENTITIES THAT ARE. NOT ACTUALLY
IN COMPLIANCE. WE REMOVE LIMITS
ON THE TOOLS AND TIME FRAMES OF
DISCHARGES CAN USE TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WE'VE NARROWED THE
BILL DOWN- IN FACT TO ITS CORE
OBJECTIVE TO ELIMINATE THE
WORST POLLUTION SO THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE CLEAN WATER STATEWIDE
BY TWENTY FIFTY. THE ORIGINAL
CLEAN WATER ACT FELL SHORT
BECAUSE IT WAS A PRACTICAL. OUR
BUILT MUST BE PRACTICAL AND
MUST BE ACHIEVABLE. I MUST BE
EFFECTIVE AND THAT'S A BALANCE
I KNOW WE CAN STRIKE. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE DEMONSTRATED BOTH A
COMMITMENT TO THE GOALS OF THIS
BILL AND A GENUINE WILLINGNESS
TO SEEK OUT INPUT AND MAKE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO GET
US THERE. THE NEED TO CLEAN UP
OUR WATERWAYS IS ABSOLUTELY
URGENT- SO MANY OF- ARE A OUR
DISTRICTS AND- REGIONS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE COUNTING ON US-
TO FIND A WAY TO IMPROVE WATER
QUALITY AND TO GET THIS DONE.
AS A WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
AND WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY ARE
SHAUNA BOTHWELL OBJECTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE. AND
CATHERINE A PIECE WHO'S THE
DIRECTOR OF SCIENCE AND POLICY
HILL THE BAY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU AND THANKS FOR
AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH US
TONIGHT YOU'RE ONE OF THE MOST
CONSCIENTIOUS PEOPLE I KNOW SO
THANK YOU AND I KNOW WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. SO WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
TESTIFYING ON THE PHONE LINE.
FIRST MATH MISTER SHAWN.
BOTHWELL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COAST COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE-
PLEASE PROCEED- WHEN YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH OR FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR COWORKING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHEN SOME OF ALL ON THE
EXECUTIVE THE COMPANY
CONSTITUENTS- I'M GONNA GET
STRAIGHT TO THE POINT BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF ATTENTION
ALREADY DISCUSSED ON THIS BILL-
WE WORKED REALLY HARD TO LISTEN
TO THE OPPOSITION AND ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS THE BROWN'S
AMENDMENTS. ARE TO CLARIFY THE
BILL MAKE THE BILL MORE
WORKABLE AND TO REMOVE
REASONABLE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES- BUT WHEN YOU GET
DOWN TO THE HEART OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL FOUR TO CREATE SOME
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
POLLUTERS AND THAT IS JUST
SOMETHING THE OPPOSITION IS NOT
WILLING TO SUPPORT. NEXT YEAR
THE FIFTY YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF
THE CLEAN WATER ACT AT
THROUGHOUT THAT TIME DISCHARGES
HAVE BEEN LEGALLY REQUIRED CAN
MEET WATER QUALITY LINENS.
DISCHARGING POLLUTION FOR ONE
REGION'S A PRIVILEGE NOT A
RIGHT. BUT A PRIVILEGE COMES
WITH LIMITS. IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DISCHARGE POLLUTION YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO MEET THE PERMITTED
WATER QUALITY LIMITS WITHIN
YOUR OWN PURPOSE. RATHER THAN
TAKE THEIR ENERGY TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW DISORDERS IS SPENT
DECADES ROBBING THE WATER
BOARD'S TO SHIELD THEM FROM
COMPLIANCE. LOWER STANDARDS AND
EXTEND COMPLIANCE DENMARK. AND
MOST TROUBLING OF ALL ARE THE
WATER BOARD'S BEAMING POLLUTERS
IN COMPLIANCE WHEN THEY ARE
ACTUALLY IN COMPLIANCE AND IT
WON'T BE FOR DECADES. TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE WATER BOARDS DO
NOT ENFORCE WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS. WATER BOARDS WILL
ENFORCE ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES LIKE NOT SUBMITTING A
REPORT ON TIME. FOLLOWING TO
ENFORCE WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS ESTATE PLUS
PERFORMANCE REPORT THE
WATERBOARDING BENEFIBER THREE
THOUSAND STORMWATER VIOLATIONS.
IN JUST THE VIOLATIONS
IDENTIFIED ONLY SIXTEEN OF THEM
WERE ENFORCED UPON. THAT IS
LESS THAN HALF A PERCENT OF THE
TIME THE WATER BOARD'S PURSUED-
ENFORCEMENT. ACTION FOR WATER
QUALITY VIOLATIONS. WHAT IS NOW
IN HOLD POLLUTERS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR MEETING THEIR- WATER
QUALITY STAY. USING THEIR NEW
INCOME POINTS WITHIN OUR LIFE.
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE. THE
BILL NOT TAKE AWAY THE
WATERBOARDING HIS. IN ONLY SIX
WATER BY BE. OVER A- ONES THE
BILL LONGER CONTAIN MANDATE TO
RESTORE OUR WATER BUT FIFTY
ONLY A- FOR STORMS. I WENT TO
THE BILL SO IN FOR POINT BACK
TO CAN YOU. THAT WAS HARMED THE
VIOLATION THE WAY THE ORIGINAL
FORM OF INTENDED TO FUNCTION.
THE CURRENT VERSION OF A THREE
SOME SEVEN IS NOT ISN'T.
OVERHAUL OF REGULAR SO. THE WAY
AUTOMATION OPPOSITION LIKE YOU
TO BELIEVE BUT IT A STEP
TOWARDS SOME ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
POLLUTERS TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW. BUT I AFTER I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU- SO MR BOSCO A USED
TWO MINUTES AND THIRTY SECONDS
SO. UP MISS PIECE ON BEHALF OF
HEAL THE BAY. UP TRYING TO KEEP
IT TO A MINUTE THIRTY IF YOU
GOT IT TOO I WON'T COMPLAIN TOO
MUCH BUT- TRYING TO KEEP IT
BRIEF THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CARE CORK AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR KATHERINE
PEASE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AND POLICY AND HEAL THE
BAY. I AM SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN. AB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL PUT CALIFORNIA BACK ON
TRACK TO MEET WATER QUALITY
OBJECTIVES BY TWENTY FIFTY. AS
INTENDED IN THE CLEAN WATER ACT.
WITH THE IMPACTS OF WATER
QUALITY IMPAIRMENTS AND LACK OF
PROGRESS FIRSTHAND IN LOS
ANGELES. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
HEAL THE BAY PUBLISHED A
COMPREHENSIVE STORM WATER
REPORT EXAMINING PROGRESS OR
LACK THEREOF IN STORMWATER
POLLUTION REDUCTION EFFORTS AND
L. A. COUNTY. WE REVIEWED DATA
FROM TWELVE WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT GROUPS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
STORM WATER PROJECTS. DESPITE
OUR REGION HAVING HAD NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS TO ADDRESS
STORMWATER POLLUTION AND SIXTY
YEARS TO EXECUTE THE LATEST
VERSION OF THE PLAN WE FOUND
THAT AS OF DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE RESPONSIBLE GROUPS
THAT WE LOOKED AT ARE ONLY
ABOUT 9% COMPLETE TOWARDS FINAL
GOLD. IF THE CURRENT RATE OF
IMPLEMENTATION CONTINUES. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY GROUPS WILL
ACHIEVE THEIR TOTAL COLLECTIVE
GOAL IN TWENTY EIGHTY TWO WELL
PAST THAT FINAL DEADLINES
RANGING FROM. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN.
MEANWHILE OUR WATER WAYS AND
COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING. THE
L. A. RIVER IS OFFICIALLY
LISTED AS IMPAIRED FOR AT LEAST
TWENTY DIFFERENT COLOR. THE
RIVER FLOWS YOUR SEVENTEEN
DIFFERENT CITIES INCLUDING MANY
AREAS AND COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
THE HIGHEST POLLUTION BURDENS
ACCORDING TO CALLAN VIRUS
SCREEN. THE PEOPLE OF LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA DESERVE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO STAYS CLEAN
WATER. WE CANNOT CONTINUE WITH
BUSINESS AS USUAL AND AB THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL RESET THIS
IS MOTOR DIRECTORY THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY ON. WE ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE TODAY. OUR WATER WAYS
AND COMMUNITY AND GET US BACK
ON TRACK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
NEXT PERSON TO SPEAK IS TERESA
DUNHAM. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL AND
CALIFORNIA COTTON GROWERS
ASSOCIATION PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU AT THREE THE DOWN ON
THE CONCERT IN CONWAY YEAH MY
TESTIMONY TODAY IS NOT ONLY ON
BEHALF OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
IDENTIFIED BY MISTER CORK BUT
ALSO OTHER INDUSTRY AND PUBLIC
ENTITIES THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
OUR STATE AND FEDERAL WATER
QUALITY LAWS. WE CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL WOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAYS
IN WHICH THE STATE REGIONAL
WATER BOARDS REGULATE
DISCHARGES FROM AGRICULTURE AND
OTHERS THISBILL CALLS FOR A
PLAN FOR BRINGING ALL WATER
SEGMENTS INTO A PAYMENT BY
TWENTY FIFTEEN. ALTHOUGH A LOT
OF THE GOAL OF THIS PLAN WOULD
BE IMPOSSIBLE AND IMPRACTICAL
TO PREPARE FOR MANY REASONS FOR
EXAMPLE WATER SEGMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT JUST RIVERS
AND CREEKS BUT ALSO INCLUDE
AGRICULTURAL. DRAINS HM BY FOR
FLOOD. AND CAN BE TO SELL. MORE%
IMPORTANTLY BRINGING WATERS TO
INTO IT. PRISON SEVERAL KEY ON.
ONE THAT ONE QUALITY ARE. WHICH
THEY ARE NOT. THAT WE KNOW WHAT
WE TO DO TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WHICH WE DOUBT. AND THAT WE-
HAVE THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
IMPLEMENT EVEN IF WE KNEW WHAT
TO DO WHICH WE DON'T. REGARDING
THE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS THEY
GO WELL BEYOND JUST ENFORCING
CORRECT AND THAT. THE
TERMINOLOGY OF CULTURE
CONTRIBUTE TO MAKE STUDENTS OF
A WATER QUALITY STANDARDS IS
NOT SIMPLE TO INTERPRET. OR
APPLY TO MANY TYPE DISCHARGES.
AGRICULTURE AND STORMWATER
AMONG OTHERS. WE DO NOT HAVE
MATHIS TO MEASURE. OR DETERMINE
CULTURE CONTRIBUTE. I WILL
CULTURE JUST LIKE ME THAT GO WE
NEED TOMORROW WHAT LEAVING
SEVEN MILLION. IRRIGATED ACRES
ALONG. LAND AT THE EDGE OF THE
FIELD. AND AN EXPENSIVE AND
IMPOSSIBLE ENDEAVOR. WHAT IT
MEAN DURING THE LIABLE UNDER
THIS. I DON'T THINK IT AND
APOSS OF COLOGNE AFFECTED FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER DAY AND FOR
AN IN PDF HOLDER TEN THOUSAND
PER DAY. UNDER THE LEGISLATION
DALY. WOULD CONTINUE UNTIL A
DESTRUCTIVE COULD PROVE THAT
THEY ARE NO LONGER CAUSING A
CONTRIBUTING TO AN ACCIDENT WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
DEMONSTRATION APPROVED WOULD
ENTAIL. BUT EVEN MANY REASONS
VIEWING OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KAREN COLON. ON
HER CALENDAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STORM WATER QUALITY
ASSOCIATION CASCO- GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KAREN CALLANAN NINETY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STORM WATER QUALITY
OF FIFTY ASIAN. TODAY I'LL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBER THROUGHOUT THE CITY
COUNTY AND STATE AGENCIES BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BECAUSE BUDGET.
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN AS AMENDED
CONTINUE TO PROPOSE
CIRCUMVENTING THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY IN THE STATE AND
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS BY
UNNECESSARILY REMOVING
COMPLIANCE OPTIONS IN COMBAT.
FOR MAYBE NEED OPTION HAS REAL
IMPACT IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL PERSPECTIVE
PERMITTING COMPLIANCE OPTIONS
WILL UNDERMINE REGIONAL
STORMWATER CAPTURE PROJECTS AS
WELL AS OTHER INTEGRATED
SOLUTIONS THAT RESULT NOT ONLY
IN IMPROVE WATER QUALITY BUT
ALSO INCREASE WATER SUPPLY.
RECENT COMMENTS AND LYFT COUNTY
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE BAY
HAPPEN SPENT THE INTEGRATED. TO
GET THE ADVANCING AND A GREAT
WATERMAN. AB THREE SEVEN WOULD
REDUCE THE- OPTION OFF THE-
LIVES FOR AGENT. THE NET EFFECT
OF THE ETHNIC RATE. OF THE
AFFECTED SOLUTION. FROM AT THE
PERSPECTIVE A STRONG PART OF
ARE ON A EXCLUSIVELY THROUGH
LOCAL CHANNEL FUND THE CARD
PENALTY BUT OFF BE PAID OF
GENERAL FUND. LIMITED LOOK
RESOURCE WITH THEREFORE BE TO
FROM QUALITY PRORAM IT IS NAY
THINK WHY FORTUNATE PROGRAM
WHERE THE YOUTH OF THE WOULD BE
THREE LIMITED TO ADDITION
IMPORTS NOTABLY NOT TEN WATER.
THIS APPROACH THEY WORK FINE.
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE PUBLIC
RESOURCES ARE RESPONSIBLY
INVESTED TO ACHIEVE THE BEST
OUTCOME POSSIBLE FIVE MEMBERS
ALL SHARE THE SAME GOAL FOR THE
PROTECTION OF BENEFICIAL USES
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN MINUTES UP
FARTHER AWAY FROM ACHIEVING
THAT GOAL. I'M NOT THE LINER
DESIRED OUTCOMES WITH
COMPLIANCE AND PERMITS WE NEED
TO INCENTIVIZE INTEGRATED WATER
MANAGEMENT AND PROVIDE MORE NOT
LESS FUNDING. TO OUR COMMUNITY
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN WOULD
ACHIEVE THE OPPOSITE OUTCOME
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE
NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. WILL NOW GET
COMMENTS- FROM- NOW I'VE GOT.
I'M RUSHING AGAIN ALL RIGHT
FIRST OF ALL ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND WE
DON'T SEE ANYONE. AND THEN
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM IF IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IF YOU'RE THERE
PLEASE SPEAK UP. ALL RIGHT-
THEN MR OPERATOR IT LET'S HEAR
SUPPORT FIRST AND THEN WE'LL
HEAR OPPOSITION. AGAIN JUST
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME FOR AB
THREE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE PLACE YOU BACK
IN THE QUEUE SOCIAL SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE'LL
START WITH LINE TWENTY EIGHT
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING BRING AND ALSO
WITH THE ARTICLE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU LINE ONE
OH FOUR. AMERILA THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF VOTERS AND STRONG.
REAL GOOD LINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CAITLYN CLOUD
PROVIDING STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF EASTER COMMITTEE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY SEVENTH
GENERATION ADVISORS CALIFORNIA
COUPLE PROTECTION NETWORK
ENVIRONMENT ACTION HAVE A
COMMITTEE OF WEST MARIN AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
AGAIN IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I WILL GO TO LINE NINETY
EIGHT. AND NINETY EIGHT MISTER.
ONE SECOND. I WILL TRY LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS TO
CHAIRED JUSTIN ALONE ON BEHALF
OF THE ELEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
TEAM SEES LOBBY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND LINE EIGHTY YOU
ARE OPEN. THIS IS ANDREA
VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT- THAN THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
CHAU OPPOSITION ON AB THREE
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOBODY IS
KILLING UP MISTER CHAIR. OKAY
THANK YOU- SO THEN WORLD START
WITH QUESTIONS. WELL. OKAY
MISTER MAHER CG. THIS SERVICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE- OBVIOUSLY I SUPPORT.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WE ALL
WANT CLEAN WATER- YOU KNOW NOT
ONLY THE- DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEARING
THE BRUNT OF. THE POLLUTED
WATER- BUT- YEAH EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF US ON THIS DIED SO I
THINK THAT MY CONCERN- AND IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE AMENDMENTS-
HAVE A ADDRESSED A LOT OF THEM
AND SO. I MAY JUST NEED TO. YOU
KNOW GET TO. MANY OF MY CITIES
IN MY DISTRICT THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TO
FULLY ANALYZE AND APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS- BUT- YEAH THAT
THAT'S MY BASIC CONCERN THAT- I
KNOW I JUST KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW
EVER SINCE I'VE- ARRIVED IN THE
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN IN
TWENTY TWELVE- THAT- OFF ALL OF
MY CITIES HAVE- YOU KNOW
EMPHASIZED LIKE HOW THEY'RE- AT
RISK OF BEING BANKRUPT- WITH
THE- M. S. FOUR IN THE- OTHER
OBLIGATIONS. AND SO. YEAH YOU
KNOW I YOUR YOUR BILL YOUR
AMENDED BILL MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE ADDRESSED MANY OF THESE
ISSUES- THE COULD YOU TALK
ABOUT. IF YOU WERE TALKING TO
MY CITIES- ON HOW THIS BILL IS
NOT GOING TO- INCREASE
LIABILITY REMOVE COMPLIANCE
OPTIONS YOU KNOW- DECREASE
LOCAL RESOURCES TO- TO FIND
STORMWATER- AND LESS FUNDING
OVERALL FOR STORM WATER
MANAGEMENT. IMAGE BASICALLY
THOSE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
STORM WATER ASSOCIATION SURE
WELL I APPRECIATE- THE COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE MINUTES
WE HAVE MADE WE'VE DONE SO.
PROACTIVELY AS I MENTIONED
BASED ON THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WE'VE- WE'VE ASKED-
ALL OPPOSITION TO PROVIDE. US
WITH LANGUAGE AND AMENDMENTS
THA WOULD ALLEVIATE THEIR
CONCERNS. AND THEY'RE NOT DONE
SO AND SO WE TOOK THE
INITIATIVE WORKING WITH-
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR. TO ADDRESS HIS
CONCERNS AS BEST WE CAN AND IN
THIS IS SOMETHING WE YOU KNOW
THIS IS A DISCUSSION THIS IS
WORK THAT WILL CONTINUE YEAH WE
WANT TO EAT IT WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENGAGE
THEM- THE YOUNG CERTAINLY JUST
WHAT WHAT WE HEARD ABOUT THE
CONCERNS ABOUT ENFORCEMENT. YOU
KNOW THE WHOLE GOAL AROUND- AND
FORESEEN- YOU KNOW BY
ENFORCEMENT AS IT SUGGESTS IN
THIS BILL. IS THAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT YOU
KNOW THIS IS A FORM OF BOUNTY
HUNTING I'M GOING TO GO AFTER
THESE. THESE AFFORDABLE
DISTRICTS. YOU KNOW AND SO AND
FORCING OUR LAWS HERE IN THE
STATE CREATES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND- A FAIR ON. A PLAYING
FIELD- IT'S- CERTAINLY THAT YOU
KNOW ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE GOOD
ACTORS- THE SMALLER DISTRICTS
THAT PLAY BY THE RULES- IN THAT
HAVE ALREADY MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN MEETING. WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS- YOU KNOW IN
IN THEIR EFFORT TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW YOU KNOW AND YOU KNOW
THE ONE EXAMPLE YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT- I WOULD
RELATE TO IS YOU KNOW WE DON'T
SET SPEEDING LIMITS. AND THEN
NOT GIVE OUT SPEEDING TICKETS
NOW AND IT YOU KNOW SO WHY
SHOULD WE SET WATER QUALITY
LIMITS AND THE NOT HOLD BAD
ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE- AND SO WITH
THAT YOU KNOW TO SPECIFICALLY
ANSWER QUESTION I'D PROBABLY
TURN IT OVER TO. THE TO- ONE OF
THE SPONSORS- MR- MISTER
BOTHWELL- SEAN- WHOSE- WITH
THE- THE CUSTOMER ALLIANCES
WORKS VERY CLOSELY. WITH A LOT
OF THESE YOU KNOW LOCAL
ENTITIES HI SEAN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YEAH I'M HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TO ANSWER THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION SO THE
CONCERNED TEAM FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN IN LOS ANGELES
SPECIFICALLY IS THEY HAVE THIS
STORM WATER PERMIT WHICH WILL
BE DISCUSSED- BOB. DEANS CITIES
AND COUNTIES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
OUR STANDARDS EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT SO LONG AGO AT THIS POINT
FROM THE COMPLIANCE WITHIN THE
NEXT TEN YEARS I'M SO HAPPY AT
THE OPENING ORIGINAL BILL HAD
SUPERVISION UNIT. THAT HAD ONE
THAT SAID WATER BOARDS YOU
SHALL NOT BEING PEOPLE IN
COMPLIANCE WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE BUT IT HAD A
COMPLAINT SCHEDULED TO SAY YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
ALTERNATIVE COMPLIANCE UNTIL
TWENTY THIRTY. AND THEN
POSSIBLE EXTENSIONS TO TWENTY
FORTY. THAT THOSE TWO
PROVISIONS ARE THE HEART OF
WHAT WAS THE CONCERN OF BOTH
LOCAL CITIES AND RAISING THE
ISSUES OF CAUCUS THAT THE THAT
PART OF THE BILL HAD BEEN
REMOVED. SO THAT IS NO LONGER
CONCERNED CITIES AND COUNTIES
THEY THEN SO CITY LOS ANGELES
HOW THIS STATE HARBOR IN THEIR
PERMITS- SO LONG AS THEY'RE
MEETING THEIR PLAN- THEY CAN'T
BE ENFORCED AGAIN SO THIS BILL
ACTUALLY ONE IMPACTED THEM AT
ALL BECAUSE THE SAFE HARBOR IS
CURRENTLY SHIELDING THEMFROM
ANY TYPE OF ENFORCEMENT. SO
LONG AS THEY DO WHAT THEY SAID
THEY WOULD DO ALL WITHIN THEIR
PLAN THAT'S PART OF THEIR
APARTMENT SO I DON'T SEE THE
COSTA CITIES- OCCURRING ANYTIME
SOON CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW AGAIN
WHEN THE SAFE HARBOR SHIELDS
GOES AWAY- AND THEY'RE STILL
BAD ACTORS OUT THERE ALL THIS
BILL DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE
WATER BOARD'S THE DISCUSSION.
TO PRIORITIZE WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL CURRENTLY DOES WE
WE'VE REMOVED REALLY THE HEART
THAT SAID YOU CAN'T KEEP PEOPLE
COMPLIANCE MEETING COMPLIANCE.
WITHIN THE NEXT WITHIN THE NEXT
DECADE. THROUGH THE CHAIR IT IF
I MAY. ADDRESS THE QUESTION A
FOLLOW QUESTION TO BE WITNESS.
SO WHAT YOU MISTER WELL I KNOW
THAT THOUGH IT WE TO- SO
OPPORTUNITY TO. SPELL BOTH
DIRECTLY AS WELL AS TO MY
STAFF- MY MAIN CONCERN IS THAT
I KNOW A LOT OF MIGHT BITE MY
CITIES- YOU KNOW AT. AS COASTAL
CITIES YOU KNOW THEY THEY- ARE
HAVE TOLD ME THAT- THEY ARE
HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY OF
THE POLLUTANTS THAT COME
DOWNSTREAM. FROM THE REST OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AND SO
THERE COULD THEIR CONCERN HAS
BEEN THAT THEY HAVE ALWAYS.
BORNE THE BRUNT OF CLEANING UP
THE MESS THAT COMES FROM THE
REST OF L. A. COUNTY. I DON'T
KNOW IF FOR. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA YOU KNOW CAN
ENLIGHTEN US WITH HIS
EXPERIENCE AS THE FORMER MAYOR
OF SANTA MONICA. BUT- YEAH SO I
GUESS- YOU KNOW I AM CONCERNED
THAT NOT WITHSTANDING WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES CONTINUES TO BE IN
OPPOSITION- AND- SO AGAIN I.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY I WANT TO BE
WITH ALL MY FRIENDS THAT I SEE
ON YOUR SUPPORT LIST- WANT TO
BE WITH YOU MISTER REAVIS- BUT-
YOU KNOW I CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE SUPPORT THIS WITHOUT
FOR THE CLARIFICATION AS TO
THE- THE COST- IMPLICATIONS FOR
MY CITIES. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER MURATSUCHI- SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER ON THE PHONE LINES THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE ME TO USE IN
OPPOSITION DIDN'T GET A CHANCE
TO SPEAK. SO MR OPERATOR COULD
YOU BRING THEM ONLINE. THANK
YOU- IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW.
OPPOSITION TO ARE WE STILL ON
AB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN MISTER
CHAIR YES THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU SO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION FOR
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN- PLEASE GO
AHEAD HIT ONE ZERO AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH DIFFERENCE MAKERS HAVE
FAILED WITH THE CITY OF REDDING
OPPOSE. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
FIVE YOU ARE UP. SALARY NARAL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE OPPOSED. FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ME NOW LEYVA
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS WE ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MELISSA HI DO ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS LIKE
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ON WE
WILL GO TO Y. NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON KHAKI
MCCUE CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE
HOSTS THANK YOU. ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH A NEW
FORTY TWO. WHY FORTY TWO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO. CHAU OPPOSITION.
ARE MOVING ALONG WITH A LITTLE
LIGHT NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
MENIFEE PERRIS IN SANTA. IN THE
SOUTH ON A WATERSHED WE ARE WE
DO OPPOSE THIS BILL THE WATER
BOARDS ALREADY HAVE THE STORY.
AND ONE EMPIRE WE HAVE MADE
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE HINDERED ALL OF OUR
PROGRESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ARLENE JOHN
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SAN
SANTA ANA MOJAVE RIVER
WATERSHED WE OPPOSE AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU. I NINETY
DIED YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS
SHAWN PORTER ON BEHALF OF THIS
SAN DIEGO INDUSTRIAL
ENVIRONMENTALISTS SOCIAIS
ASIAN- WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL- OVER REACHING AND
DRACONIAN IN NATURE THANK YOU.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS THAT THEIR DOLPHY ON
BEHALF OF WEEKLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN OPPOSITION AND I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
LINE ONE TIP PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS TRUDIE
HUGHES IN THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
IF THE PRODUCERS REPRESENTING
THREE PROCESSOR PROCESSOR FOR
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE FORTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
PLEASE ON MUTE. FORTY FIVE. I
FORTY FIVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SHOW OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
WELL THE ONE WE WERE LINE ONE
ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
ALSO. GOOD MORNING JAMIE MINOR
BE HAPPENSTANCE MARGOT RENO
WATER DISTRICT IN EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FIND ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JULIE HALL THE
DISSERTATION OF CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY COMPETE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING
COOK MAUREEN ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU LIVE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING. FOUR HUNDRED. IN
OPPOSITION. FIVE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THAT THE DOCTOR GOGGLE AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN
YOU ARE UP. HI THIS IS GREAT
CAPTAIN EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE GATEWAY WATER MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY REPRESENTING TWENTY
SIX CITIES AND SOUTHEAST L. A.
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ANGELA CLAP
WITH THE PORT OF OAKLAND CLEAN
WATER PROGRAM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LINE.
SEVENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
CHANGE SHOULD BE TO THE CITY OF
POWER IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIFTY THREE PLEASE ON MUTE. BY
FIFTY THREE. ARE MOVING ALONG
WITH A LINE FORTY FOUR. I GET
AFTERNOON DARCY CAN BE ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FLOOD CONTROL AND WATER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT
REPRESENTING THREE WATERSHED IN
TWENTY EIGHT CITIES IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY ONE ARE YOU
MUTED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING VALYA FADHEL WOULD
CONTINUE RANCHO CORDOVA IN
OPPOSITION. BY TWENTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DANNY
MERKLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. FIND EIGHTY ONE YOU
ARE OFFERED. LINE EIGHTY ONE
ARE YOU MUTED. HI GAIL CALLAHAN
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. I KNOW EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JACK LEARY ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WHERE POST. LINE.
EIGHTY TWO. TWENTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF THREE VALUED
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRTH BEST
A LOT SO ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
ANA WATCH WATERSHED PROJECT
AUTHORITY WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBEKAH
BATONS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION
GOVERNORSHIP OR TO TEACH AN
ESSENTIAL CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
PISTACHIO GROWERS CALIFORNIA
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA WALNUT COMMISSION
WESTERN AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND WESTERN PLANT
HEALTH ASSOCIATION ALL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN YOU ARE ALL
BUT. DANIEL BY PROVIDING WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LINE ONE
NINETEEN YOU ARE OPEN. THE
MORNING ALLOW MATIC ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF ROSELLE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO ONE EIGHTEEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BRUCE DAVIS
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
CONCORD AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT IS WIDE. FORTY
TWO. FORTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS DR KIRTLEY
PROGRAM MANAGER. STORMWATER
PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF TWELVE
SMALL BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES AS
OPPOSED. THREE SEVEN THE-
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MEDICARE NETWORK.
GOOD MORNING MR HERE NUMBER TO
CHECK ON YOUR WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR AND
CONSULTED ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD IN OPPOSITION. BY.
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
OF KILLARNEY RD CANTON I ON
BEHALF OF THE IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT AND ALSO EACH
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. I TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN ONE TWENTY ONE
YOU ARE OKAY BUT- THANK YOU
THIS IS NOT ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY COUNTY ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY WHERE THE STORM WATER
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAM
MANAGERS THERE- IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK CRISTINA ROW
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DIVISION OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES REPRESENT
EIGHTY SIX CITIES AND THE
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION. AND AS A
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION ON THIS- ON AB THREE
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ADAM HARPER WITH THE CALGARY
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL MUCH OF
THE SITUATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHT. WE WILL GO
ALL. DO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS JAMISON CROSBY WITH THE NAPA
COUNTY WIDE STORM WATER
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAMS
AND WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ONE ONE HUNDRED TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ABOUT ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO THE
MORNING WHAT THE MASANYA
RESIDENT OF REDDING AND SHASTA
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION SB. THREE
SEVEN SEVEN. LINE ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TIM SCHMELTER
WINE INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE HUNDRED
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOMINIC
TOMORROW ABOUT HALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER EXCHANGE
CONTRACTORS WATER AUTHORITY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FINAL
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
ON MUTE. YES ME THAT YOU. YES
GOOD MORNING- THIS IS DAHLIA
BOTTLE WITH CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES IT'S OUTLINED
CONSULTANT FOR THE COUNTRY CODE
THE CLEAN WATER PROGRAM IN THE
BAY AREA REPRESENTING NINETEEN
THIRTY THE COUNTY AND THE
COUNTRY CODE COUNTY BUT UNTIL
DISTRICT. ALL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND I MISSED YOUR
THAT'S WE HAVE A- DEPLETED THE
Q. OKAY WELL THAT WAS- THAT WAS
ELEVEN MINUTES AND TWENTY
SECONDS OF TESTIMONY THAT WE
MISSED- JONES HOPEFULLY THAT
WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN. I LET'S SEE
OTHER COMMENTS FROM OR
QUESTIONS. UP MISTER VICE CHAIR
AFTER LISTENING FOR ABOUT
ELEVEN OR TWELVE MINUTES SIR
MISTER RIVAS WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO ON THIS BILL AND NOW
A LOT OF THOSE OF OPPOSED TO
COME FROM MY DISTRICT SO I WILL
STAY WITH MY DISTRICT CURRENTLY
BE OPPOSED TO THIS. LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS IN THE
FUTURE BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
LEAVES A LOT MORE WORK TO BE
DONE SIR THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY
I APPRECIATE COMMENT. GO AHEAD
MISTER MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- MISTER REVERSES IS YOUR
VICE CHAIR OF AGRICULTURE ON
AND SEEN THE LONG LIST OF
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- ESPECIALLY
WITH YOUR STATUS AS CHAIR OF AG-
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND. YOU TO
TALK TO OUR OUR PEOPLE WE
REPRESENT ON THAT SIDE- AND
REALLY WORK. DILIGENTLY ON
THIS- A TRUST THAT YOU WILL-
BUT AT THIS TIME A HARD NO ON
THIS SURE. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- SIMILAR MATHIS AND-
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
THAT I NOT ONLY WILL BUT I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
WE'VE ENGAGED IN FROM DAY ONE-
AND WE WILL CONTINUE ENGAGE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- THE COOPERATE- HE
DID ACTUALLY ASK YOU A QUESTION
LCR SIGN UP. ALL SET UP FOR MY
CLOSING NEXT A MS BAUER QUE HAN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY MISS REAVIS-
INTO THE COMMITTEE THAT IT'S
CLEAR INCREDIBLE WORK HAS GONE
INTO. MAKING THIS BILL WORKABLE
AND I WANNA CREDIT BOTH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND YOU FOR
DOING THAT WORK SO FAR WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO FIGURE OU
HOW TO GET THERE. I THINK AT
THIS POINT THE BILL IS PRETTY
SIMPLE RIGHT IT'S ASKING US TO
DO WHAT WE ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
TO DO TO PROVIDE CLEAN WATER TO
CALIFORNIA AND THE FACT OR
FAILING TO DO THAT TODAY. IS
FAILURE ON THE PART OF THE
GOVERNMENT IN YOUR PUSHING THE
GOVERNMENT TO GET TO WHERE WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO ALREADY BE.
FEELS LIKE A NO BRAINER TO ME
AND SO I DO. AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE THAT
FEASIBLE AND YOU'VE ALREADY
DONE INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF THAT
WORK AND I TRUST YOU TO
CONTINUE TO DO IT SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING US THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MS GARCIA. I
WANT TO SPEAK A- HAD SOME OF MY
LOCAL. CITY SPEAK UP AND
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW AND THE
ROUND OF AMENDMENTS
GROUNDWATER. IS NOT INCLUDED
AND- IN THIS BILL WHICH IS. OUR
MAIN SOURCE OF CONCERN AND- MY
DISTRICT I HAVE. A LOT OF
CONTAMINATION DOWN THERE AND SO
I APPRECIATE. WHERE THIS BILL
IS GOING- IT'S BEEN. DONE
QUITE. A BIT AND- I WISH IT
WASN'T- AND HONESTY AND SAID
JUST WANNA. I WANNA ENCOURAGE
THE OPPOSITION TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND WORK IN A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER. PROVIDING
SAFE. WATER FOR. CALIFORNIANS
TO BE SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
WORK TOWARDS AND- IT'S TOO HARD
TO DO WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IN A
CERTAIN WAY IS NOT. IS NOT A
GOOD ENOUGH REASON NOT TO DO
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING AND
SO. MY MESSAGE IS FOR THE FOR
THE OPPOSITION TO. COME TO THE
TABLE AND WORK WITH US THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD- I DON'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE WITH QUESTIONS.
ARM SO FIRST DON'T ASK FOR A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER REAVIS YOU MAY CLOSE
ORGAN- APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND-
THIS COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR AND
YOU KNOW AS I WAS MENTIONING TO
SOMEONE MATHIS YOU KNOW I WILL.
WE'LL CONTINUE MYSELF MY STAFF-
WILL CONTINUE ENGAGE OPPOSITION
ESPECIALLY AGRICULTURE AS WE
HAVE- BUT AS WAS STATED BY- OUR
COLLEAGUE YOU KNOW THIS IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE I HEARD THE
COMMENTS. OVER REACHING AND- I
TO A DRACONIAN BILL IN NATURE I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW THE LACK
OF PROGRESS- THAT THAT THAT
THAT WE HAVE MADE YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER. DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. TO CLEAN
RECREATIONAL WATERS IN THE
STATE. THE POLLING- WHEN I HEAR
THINGS LIKE OVERREACH AND
DRACONIAN WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
AND REMEDIATE THESE ISSUES AND
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF ALL OF THESE.
ENTITIES THAT HAVE CALLED IN-
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THESE THESE THESE GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL AGENCIES WITH REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT POWERS- WHO ARE
HAVE BEEN UNWILLING. OR UNABLE
TO COMPEL COMPLIANCE WITH
CURRENT POLLUTION CONTROLS OF
PERMITS- AND PARTICULARLY IN
OUR STATES LESS A FLUENT INLAND
AREAS ARE MOST IMPOVERISHED
REGIONS. AND AND IT'S A SHAME.
AND I YOU KNOW RESPECT THEIR
OPPOSITION BUT THE FACT THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN UNWILLING TO
ENGAGE IN OFFER- RECOMMENDED
LANGUAGE TO GET US INTO A BUT
WE ALL PLACE TO. TO MAKE THE
CHANGES IMPROVEMENTS WE NEED-
IS A PROBLEM YOU KNOW BUT I
CERTAINLY RESPECT ALL OF THE
COMMENTS AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL OPPOSITION ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO GET US IN A
PLACE WHERE THIS IS AGAIN. A
WORKABLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SO WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER. ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S
FACE IT THIS IS A- THE REASON
THE REASON LANGUAGE TO CURE
THIS IS BECAUSE IT'S NOT REALLY
ABOUT LANGUAGE WHAT IT'S ABOUT
IS THE JYJ COST THAT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE TO MEET THE SENATE AND
I CAN GO INTO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ON THE LANGUAGE WHICH-
I WANT AT THIS TIME BUT- IT
REALLY IS ABOUT THE MONEY IF
WE'RE GOING TO TREAT. ALL OF
OUR- STORM RUNOFF. AS WELL TO
TREATED IN AS N THE WAY THAT
WE TREAT OUR SEWAGE WHICH IS AT
SOME POINT WHAT'S GOING TO BE
NECESSARY IT'S REALLY REALLY
EXPENSIVE AND WHEN I WAS ON A
WHICH CITY COUNCIL I WAS TOLD
THOSE ISUNFUNDED MANDATE
COMING AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW
WE'RE GOING TO FORWARD IT. AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT EITHER- I DO
KNOW THAT IT'S GOT TO BE DONE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE PUTTING. ALSO
OF IT WE HAD A HURT HEARING
EARLIER WE'RE PUTTING ALL SORTS
OF PLASTIC IN TE WATER IN THIS
PREDOMINANTLY COMING FROM STORM
RUNOFF. IT'S PROBABLY PLASTIC
FROM. DRYERS THAT- PUT- PLASTIC
OUT INTO THE AIR AND THEY'RE
EXHAUSTED- LATER. ALL SORTS OF
THINGS THAT FRANKLY WON'T BE
SOLVED WITH RECYCLING AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE WOULD LIKE TO SAY
IT'S THE WAY WERE LIVING. SO I
DON'T THINK THERE IS A SOLUTION
TO THAT OTHER THAN TREATING THE
STORM WATER BUT IT'S HELLO
EXTENSIVE. SO I THINK WE HAVE
TO START BEING REALISTIC WHICH
IS IF WE REALLY WANT THE CLEAN
WATER WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
THE PLAN THAT'LL INCLUDE
FINDING- AND THAT COULD BE.
PROBABLY A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE. SO IT'S NOT
SMALL AND THAT'S JUST TALKING
ABOUT CITIES AND SEWAGE
AGENCIES BUT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS IS BALLOT IT'S A GOING TO
BE EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE TO GET
THERE. I HAVE ALSO AND SO I
HAVE CONCERNS AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION AT THE
STATE LEVEL PER A THE FOR.
LEVEL A LOT OF THESE DISTRICTS
JUST AREN'T GOING TO HAVE THE
MONEY AND SOME OF THE OTHER
DISTRICTS MIGHT BUT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE A LOT ON THE-
AGRICULTURAL SIDE WHAT ONE OF
THE OPPOSITION LEADER SAID WAS.
UP WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO DO
THIS WELL WE'D BETTER FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THIS. OUR WATER
IS PRECIOUS. AND WE'RE LOSING
SPECIES EVERY YEAR THIS IS THE
TIME OF THE ANTHROPOCENE THE
TIME WHEN MAN IS THE MAJOR.
IMPACTOR ON OUR GEOLOGY. WHAT
ARE CLIMATE. WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN
PRESERVE THE FRESH WATER THAT
WE NEED SO MUCH. THE BOUNTY OF
THE SEA. AND IF WE DON'T PLAN
IT'S GOING TO GO ON IT SEEMS
LOTS A MASS EXTINCTIONS DO WE
WANT TO BE THE CAUSE OF ANOTHER
ONE AND PERHAPS EVEN OF OUR OWN.
WE DON'T DO SOMETHING THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN SO THIS.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT SAYS THAT THEY HAVE TO COME
UP WITH AND- A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN. AND THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
TO INCLUDE WHERE IS THE MONEY
COMING FROM. AND HOW DO WE GET
A HOLD OF AGRICULTURAL WASTE.
WE ALREADY KNOW FROM- PROBLEMS
OF THE GROUND WATER WHAT EXCESS
NITROGEN. FERTILIZER TED. WE'VE
GOT TO FIND THESE PROBLEMS AND
SOLVE THEM OR- IS HE SAID THE
PLAN IT WILL GO ON FINE BUT WE
WON'T. AND THAT'S MY CONCLUSION
AND WHY I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE CERTAINLY WORK AT
STAKEHOLDERS BUT THIS IS- I CAN
TELL YOU EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND- WILL WE WILL WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. AND DO WITH THE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS PRO AND CON AND WE
WILL TRY AND COME UP WITH
SOMETHING AND WE WILL WORK AT
THIS. AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS UNTIL THE PROBLEM
SOLVED SO I'M RECOMMENDING AN
AYE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN ROBERT RIVAS THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK HIGH COURT
HI SMITH NO SMITH NO. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN OUR QUE HAN I DALY.
DALLY NO CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI. WELL BLOOM
HI MATHIS NO MATHIS NOW WITH A
THIRTY. MURATSUCHI NOT VERY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HEAR FROM MR ARAMBULA DR
RAMBLING BEFORE WE KNOW WHETHER
THE BILL PASSES MAKING
RESEARCHER. SAM THANK YOU SORRY
YES MISS GARCIA IS UP NEXT. FOR
RANGE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
THANKS FOR TAKING ON A VERY
COMPLICATED YET VERY IMPORTANT
SUBJECT WE'VE CHATTED. MY MAIN
CONCERN WITH THAT IS YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD I JUST
DIDN'T THINK THE WAS
STRONG ENOUGH AND I KNOW NOW
THAT YOU HAVE SOME- WAYS TO
MAKE THAT STRONGER SO I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE- AND
AS YOU GIVE YOUR INTRODUCTION-
PLEASE TALK TO- WHAT
ADDITIONAL- OUR- TO MANAGE YOUR
BILL THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT AND WHICH WILL WORK
WITH YOU ON- TO. BASICALLY
FORCES SOLUTION TO A VERY
DIFFICULT PROBLEM. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THAT AND
INTRODUCTION A DIFFICULT
PROBLEM BUT I JUST SAID EARLIER
THAT THAT SHOULDN'T STOP US
FROM TRYING TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. AND SELL ONE I THINK
THE CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS
AND ALSO FOR IDENTIFYING THE
COMPLEX ISSUES AND CHALLENGES
THAT LAY AHEAD OF US AS AS WE
DO THIS WORK I'M COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES YOU HAVE
IDENTIFIED INCLUDING WORKING
WITH THE WATER BOARD ON HOW
THEY CAN IMPLEMENT REGIONAL
SOLUTIONS FOR ADDRESSING SAFE
DRINKING WATER. IN SOUTHERN L.
A. COUNTY THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
REGIONAL PLAN FOR CONSOLIDATION
OF FAILING SMALL WATER AGENCIES
WHERE THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE
FOR SUSTAINABLE DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS AND OUR REGION.
COLLABORATION WITH REGIONAL
WATER LEADERS TO IDENTIFY
MEMBERS OF THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY BOARD. AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE WOULD BRING STATE
WATER BOARD ATTENTION TO ONE OF
THE STATE'S REGIONAL HOTSPOTS
ARE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THAT
HAVE PROBLEMS. PROVIDING OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH SAFE DRINKING
WATER. REQUIRES THE BOARD TO
CREATE A PETITION TITLED
COMMISSIONER FOR THE SOUTHERN
VALLEY COUNTY REGION. THE
COMMISSION A RELIEF REGIONAL
COLLABORATION TO DEVELOP A PLAN
FOR SUSTAINABLE DRINKING WATER
WHICH MADE INCLUDES
CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL AGENCIES.
THE COMMISSIONER WILL ALSO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND FUNDING AND LEAD EFFORTS TO
FIX PROBLEMS WITH CONTAMINATED
GROUNDWATER. FINALLY THE
COMMISSIONER WILL EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE CENTRAL
BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
WHERE PASSED THE AUDITS EVERY
BILL PROBLEMS. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE WHAT THE
WATER BOND WE HAVE FOCUSED OUR
ATTENTION ON FIXING WATER
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE DIFFICULTY
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER
TO CALIFORNIANS. ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER STEMMING
L. A. COUNTY AND I WOULD SAY
THAT SIMONELLI COUNTY IS
OFTENTIMES THE SOUTHEAST L. A.
COUNTY WHICH IS THE REACH AND
THE SPEAKER AND I. COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENT. I THE STATE WATERS
WERE THREE SENATE STATEWIDE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT SAFE DRINKING
WATER IDENTIFIED L. A. COUNTY
F. AMONG THE TOP FIVE COUNTIES
WITH SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AT
RISK OF FAILURE EVERYTHING YOU
SEE OTHER REPORT HIGHLIGHTED
THE FACT THAT THE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE FAILING OR ON
THE VERGE OF FAILING ARE
CONCENTRATED IN SOUTHERN L. A.
COUNTY AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
CONNECTING SOURCES FROM THE
WATER FOR DIRECTLY TO SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE FORMATION OF
TECHNICAL ADVISORY BOARD THE
BOARD WILL INCLUDE WATER
EXPERTS ON THE REGION QUALIFY
TO DEVELOP AND OFFER SOLUTIONS
TO THE WATER COMMISSIONER. THEY
SAID IN A NEWS. IN TO ASSIST IS
VERY TRICKY AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO INVITE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO MEET WITH THE CENTER TO
IMPROVE. THE BILL AB ELEVEN ANY
FIVE TO STARTING A LINE TO FIX
WATER IN A WATER IN MY REGION
THIS BILL CONNECT FEET
RESOURCES TO LOCAL DISTRICTS.
TO ASSIST IN REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE. FOR TOO LONG
SYSTEMIC RACISM HAS AFFECTED
BROWN IN BLACK COMMUNITIES.
STATIONARY POLLUTING MACHINES
HAVE BEEN ANCHORED IN
COMMUNITIES THAT LOOK LIKE MINE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
BECAUSE OF. HOW WELL I THINK I
WANNA SEE I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
PART OF THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS. BUT IF THE QUESTION
WHY SO THEN L. A. COUNTY SHOULD
GET A SPECIAL ATTENTION. I
CRAVE THEM TO LOOK AT THE
REPORTS FROM THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND UCLA THE REGION
APPROACH MAY BE A GOOD MODEL
FOR OTHER PROBLEM REGIONS. SO
WE MAY AMEND THE BILL TO
OPERATE AFTER MODEL OR A PILOT
PROJECT TO SHOW IT WORKS.
EARLIER THIS WEEK A STATE WATER
BOARD MEMBER TOLD A CONFERENCE
AT A REGIONAL APPROACH MAY BE
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE. FOR
THOSE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
PERHAPS PRIVATE PROHIBITION ON
OPERATORSHIP IN WATER RIGHTS
AND THE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM. I
WOULD REMIND THEM THAT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ON OUR
STATE WATER AND THEIR RIGHTS TO
USE THAT WATER REMAINS SUBJECT
TO STATE REGULATIONS. THAT FIND
THEIR WAY TO WORK TO MAKE US
WORK WITHINREGULATORY
STRUCTURES TO PREVENT OWNERS
MUST ALLEN ARE ABANDONING FILL
WATER SYSTEMS. TO THE STATE
WHILE KEEPING THIS IS THE MOST
VALUABLE ASSETS. UP
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY NAVEL. I'M
JUST TO CLARIFY THAN WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING. IS THAT
YOU WOULD FIRST ASK THE LOCAL
AGENCIES- INCLUDING. THE GROUND
WATER AUTHORITY TO COME UP WITH
A PLAN TO GIVE. FOUR DOUBLE
CLEAN DRINKABLE WATER AND GIVE
THEM A TIME SPAN WHICH WE CAN
TALK ABOUT IF THEY CAN'T DO
THAT THEN WE WOULD ASK THE
WATER BOARD TO TAKE A STRONGER
HANDEDNESS CORRECT OKAY. SO
THAT'S- THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
WELL WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THAT
LATER RIGHT NOW- WE'LL TALK
ABOUT- THE US SUPPORT FOR THIS
ADAN ORTEGA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA MY NAME
IS OF AN ORTEGA- I AM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S WORK ON EIGHT ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE BRINGS US FOR FULL
CIRCLE TO PROPOSITION FIFTY A
WATER BOND IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THAT WAS THE FIRST TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS FOR HELPING
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. PROP
FIFTY INCLUDED SIXTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP SMALL
WATER SYSTEM NEED THINK
CALIFORNIA NEEDS THAT IN PART
WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE STUDY OF SOUTHEAST
L. A. I HELP TO CONDUCT THAT
WESTERN CENTRAL BASIN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT WHEN I SERVED
THERE IS ASSISTANT GENERAL
MANAGER. NEEDLESS TO SAY A FEW
OF THE DOLLARS FROM PROP FIFTY
MADE IT TO SOUTHEAST L. A. IN
THE YEARS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO. DUE TO INSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES AFFECTING REGIONAL WATER
AGENCIES. THAT IN THAT AREA
THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA AND
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON HAVE
ALSO TRIED TO ADDRESS THE PAST
YEARS. JUST AS THE SAME PER
PROGRAM IS CREATING EFFECTIVE
MECHANISMS TO HELP UNDER
PERFORMING WATER SYSTEMS MOSTLY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
CENTRAL COAST. AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE WOULD CREATE MECHANISMS TO
HELP SMALL URBAN WATER SYSTEMS
TO THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
COLLABORATIVE. UNLIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN AREAS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NOW HAVE
REGIONAL WATER AGENCIES
POSITION TO HELP SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS. AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE-
COULD CREATE A TEMPLATE FOR
REMOVING OBSTACLES AND DELAYS
THESE REGIONAL AGENCIES FACE.
AND HELP BETTER LEVERAGE THEY
DOLLARS THIS WAS FIRST
ENVISIONED IN AB ONE THIRTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD
BLOOM IN TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
FAILURE TO ENACT THAT MEASURED
LED TO A COMPLETION OF A PRIMER
THAT WERE JUST PUBLISHING
OBSTACLE FACED BY LARGER WATER
SYSTEMS- THAT ARE CURRENTLY
TRYING TO HELP SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS AROUND THE STATE.
PRIMARILY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE US PICTURES
HI MY WILL NOT HELP FIND THEM
BUT THEY ARE PROVIDED IN MY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY AND IN THE
PRIMER THAT I ATTACHED TO THAT
TESTIMONY. AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVES- HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
CONSORTIUM COULD BE A
SUCCESSFUL FOLLOW UP TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE GIPSON AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. THAT
HELP TO DISSOLVE THE CITY HE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AND HELP
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
ADMINISTRATOR TO FORMULATE A
LONG TERM PLAN TO HELP THE TEAM
IS RESIDENTS ATTAIN GOOD WATER
QUALITY SERVICE AT A REASONABLE
COST. WE HAVE RECOMMENDED TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA THAT THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
COLLABORATIVE'S ADVISORY
COMMITTEE LEVERAGE WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM CITY VIA. AND
INCLUDE TECHNICAL PROFESSIONALS
FROM THE ENTITIES THAT
ENCOMPASS THE SCOPE OF
AUTHORITY AND RESOURCES NEEDED
IN CASES LIKE TO KEEP A AS WELL
AS IN HELPING LESS SEVERELY
IMPAIRED. WATER SYSTEMS. THE
TECH OKAY PATH TO THE- THROUGH
THE AB. ELEVEN NINETY FIVE CO.
DESIGN THE SETS FINANCING NEEDS
AND DETERMINE THEIR MULTIPLE
BENEFITS SUCH AS CONSERVATION
FROM REPLACING LEAKY PIPES WILL
HAVE BENEFITS THAT EXCEED THE
SPAN OF SOUTHEAST L. A. IN MANY
WAYS THE TECHNICAL CAPACITY
CREATED FOR SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
UNDER YOU. AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE IN THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER COLLABORATIVE CAN HELP
THE REGION CATCH UP TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN QUANTIFYING
NEEDS MADE POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
SAFER PROGRAM. THAT FEW WOULD
DISPUTE WAS MOSTLY FOCUSED ON
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
CENTRAL COAST. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA HAS MET WITH MANY OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN SOUTHEAST L. A.
AND HIS PLEDGE TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS TO CALIBRATE THE
BILL TO PRESIDENT NEEDS. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
ORTEGA- NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THE FIRST IS ALEX
ROWE HAAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRAL BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT A PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING
SIR I WORK IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALEX ROSS
AND I AM GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
CENTRAL BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE TWENTY
FOUR CITIES WATER DISTRICTS.
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES A NEARLY TWO
MILLION RESIDENTS WITHIN OUR
SERVICE AREA. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA
MISTER DON OR TAKE A PARTICULAR
INTEREST IN GROUND WATER
QUALITY ISSUES IN OUR SERVICE
AREA WE SHARE THE GOALS OF THE
AUTHOR TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO THE SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGION. IN
GENERAL AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR AS A
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEMBER
AGENCY WE DELIVER HIGH QUALITY
CONTAMINANT FREE DRINKING WATER
DIRECTLY TO OUR RETAIL WATER
SYSTEMS WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
COST. FOR ADDITIONAL TREATMENT.
CENTRAL BETA DOES NOT PROVIDE
GROUNDWATER TO OUR RETAIL WATER
SYSTEMS AND DOES NOT HAVE
GROUND WATER RIGHTS WHICH WE
SELL RELEASED TO RETAIL WATER
SYSTEMS. THEREFORE IT IS
UNCLEAR WHY AS A WHOLESALE
WATER UTILITY WE ARE INCLUDED
IN THIS BILL. OUR INCLUSION IN
THE BILL CREATES CONFUSION
ABOUT ITS INTENT IT DETRACTS
FROM THE VERY REAL ISSUES OF
GROUND WATER QUALITY AND THE
ONGOING GROUNDWATER TREATMENT
NEEDS OF OUR SERVICE AREA. MY
PRIMARY PURPOSE HERE TODAY IS
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
AND REGIONAL WATER SYSTEMS
WITHIN THE CENTRAL BASED ON
SERVICE AREA. OUR CUSTOMERS
HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THE
IMPACT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
ON GROUND WATER RIGHTS. LOCAL
GOVERNANCE AND DEMOCRATIC
REPRESENTATION. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THAT WILL
TO BE PASSED ONTO THE
RATEPAYERS. AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OVERSIGHT
MODEL THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
TRIED TO CITIES LIKE FLINT
MICHIGAN WITH DISASTROUS
RESULTS. THE CENTRAL BASIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN OUR
RETAIL WATER SYSTEMS DO NOT
NEED TO COMMISSIONER TO OVERSEE
OPERATIONS. NOR DO WE SEE HOW
INEXPENSIVE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CONSTRUCT HER
WILL SERVE AS A BENEFIT TO THE
REPAIRS. THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS MADE BY THE AUTHOR
AND MR TAGO ALREADY OSSIBLE
WITHOUT THE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSE OF THE
REPAIRS OR. THE PASSAGE OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE. AS NOTED BY
AUTHOR ARE MANY CHALLENGES
FACING THE SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES COUNTY REGION. BUT IN
ORDER TO HELP ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES WE NEED THE STATE TO
MORE AGGRESSIVELY FROM PROJECTS
THAT IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
DRINKING WATER. AND CREATE JOBS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES FOR THE
BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITIES.
CENTRAL BASIN DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WILL
MAKE PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING
THESE CHALLENGES AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU AND
NEXT- MISS JENNIFER. OCT
BIGELOW. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
PLEASE PROCEED. YOUR CHARACTER
CAN MEMBERS AGAIN JENNIFER
COMPUTER LOW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION HE W. A. AT THE
STATE WIDE AT THE BEACH AND
REPRESENTING DRINKING WATER
UTILITIES THAT ARE REGULATED BY
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WE PROVIDE SAFE AND RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER TO ABOUT 15% OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN THAT STATE WATER
BOARDS WORK ON WATER SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION AND WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT CONSOLIDATION IS
AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP
INSURE EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE FAITH AND RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER. OUR MEMBERS
HAVE PARTNERED WITH
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ON
CONSOLIDATION PROJECT TO
INCREASE AFFORDABILITY AND
ABOUT THEM. PARTLY IMPROVE
WATER QUALITY. AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE CREATE A GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURES FACILITATE WATER
SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION WITHIN HE
BOUNDARIES OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA WATER IF THE PATIENT
HAS FOR MEMBER COMPANIES THAT
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER SERVICE
IN THE AREA. THE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
WORK ON THAT ISSUE AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT AT DIFFERENT
SOLUTION IS NEEDED FOR SMALL
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND THE
LOS ANGELES REGION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL INCLUDES
A PROVISION THAT CREATES A
PREFERENCE. FOR A GOVERNMENT
RUN WATER DOWN OVER ANY OTHER
WATER SYSTEM CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION BELIEVES THAT THE
STATE SAID LOOK TO MAXIMIZE THE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
COMMUNITIES SUFFERING FROM
CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER. HI
RATE OR BOTH RATHER THAN CREATE
ANY LIMITATIONS ACT CURRENTLY
DRAFTED IN AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE. THE NEW GOVERNMENT ENTITY
CREATED FOR AB AND LEVIN NINETY
FIVE. WHICH STATUTORILY.
PROHIBITED FROM CONTEMPLATING A
PARTNERSHIP WITH ONE OF
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS. EVEN IF THAT WATER
SUPPLIER CAN OFFER REASONABLE
RATES AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY.
COMMUNITIES IN LOS ANGELES AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER DESERVE TO
HAVE EVERY OPTION ON THE TABLE.
WE JOINED TODAY WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL AND WE OFFER AN AMENDMENT
IN OUR LETTER TO ALLOW ANY
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS. CAN BE
CONSIDERED TO AT THE MALL
FAILING GOVERNMENTS AND LOCKED
ANGELA. THIS AMENDMENT WILL
MAXIMIZE THE PARTNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO
COMMUNITY BEN LA THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE PROVIDING SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER. TO
THE RESIDENTS. THANK YOU. WE
ARE VERY GOOD- WELL NOW CAN TO
HEAR TESTIMONY. OR ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE. I IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM IF SO
SPEAK UP IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OKAY WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
LET ME SAY FIRST THAT- YOU'LL
OUT WILL ASK YOU TO GIVE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
PETITE POSITION. AND WE'LL HEAR
FROM SUPPORT FIRST MR OPERATOR.
OKAY JUST SUPPORT FIRST
STRUCTURE YES. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SHOT TO SHOW SUPPORT
ON AB ONE ONE NINE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY ZERO.
AND AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
ON A. B. ONE NOT ONE ONE NINE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
ONE MILLION ONE QUEUING UP.
SHOULD BE WITH US MOMENTARILY.
BY ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR CORK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION MY NAME IS PAMELA
MILLER AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF LASCO. WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL BUT I DID WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THAT WE SHARE
THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE TO CALL.
THE CLEAN WATER ACCESSIBILITY
AND AFFORDABILITY ISSUES. AND
WE WANT TO THANK MISS GARCIA-
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US AND
LOS ANGELES TONER CONCERNS AND
SUGGESTIONS. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH HER THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. NOT AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM OPPOSITION.
WELL WE CAN GO TO TWENTY
MINUTES. IF NECESSARY. THANK
YOU AT THE SHOW OPPOSITION ON
AB ONE ONE NINE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
GIVE US ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE ONE NINE FIVE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JULIE HALL
AT THE SENSATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS IT'S
CURRENTLY IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE QUEUING P SERVICE ONE
SECOND. NINE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS GEORGE
BRETT AND THE GENERAL MANAGER
OVER HERE AT TRACK ONE EIGHTY
WATER COMPANY SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES SERVING VIDEO CUTTING
HAY. BALCONY VERY SMALL PART OF
SOUTH GATE AND WE ARE NOT
PARTITION OF ONE ONE NINE FIVE
AS IT IS OUR VIEW AND OPINION
THAT IT WOULD DISENFRANCHISE.
HUNDRED THOUSANDS MILLIONS OF
VOTERS. AND THE WAY I SEE IT
RIGHT NOW THAT WE SEE IF WE DO
HAVE EVERYTHING IN PLACE ALL
RIGHT. LOOK IT'S NAME WHATEVER
ORGANIZATION. AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. SO PLEASE
TELL US WHETHER YOU POSE IT.
THERE'S ALL THE PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU. I'M LET'S SEE SO
QUESTIONS. AND- WE DON'T APPEAR
TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OR
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT- MISS GARCIA
PLEASE CLOSE. AT THANK YOU I
JUST WANNA AND MY CLOTHES SEEN
MAKE A COMMENT THE CENTRAL BASE
AND DOES NOT SPEAK FOR THE
CITIES OF THE CITY IS ACTUALLY
SAYING THE CENTRAL BASIN AND
I'M ONLY THINKING A LITTLE BIT
OF TRANSPARENCY IN THEIR
OPERATIONS- AND THE
COMMISSIONERS WILL ONLY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO OVERSEE AND
OPERATE THE CENTRAL BASIN. IF
THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB WELL
THE TRANSPARENCY WILL SHOW
THEIR SUCCESS I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AS
WE WILL MOVE FORWARD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT- SO LOOK. IT'S
NOT WORKING. AND IF THE CENTRAL
BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
DOESN'T WANT TO BE PART OF THE
PROBLEM SOLUTION RATHER THAN
TALK TO THE AUTHOR. I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO BE AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO
BE. THESE GROUPS HAVE THE
OPTION UNDER THIS BILL. TO COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION. AND MY VIEW
OF THE COMMISSIONER IS A
COMMISSIONER WHO CAN HELP THE
COMMISSIONER SOMEONE WHO CAN
HELP YOU. NOT DICTATE TO YOU
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S IN THE BILL.
THE COMMISSIONER IS SOMEONE TO
HELP YOU COME UP WITH SOLUTION
GOD KNOWS SOME OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE SO SMALL. THAT THEY'D HAVE
A HELL OF A TIME STAFFING THIS
IN COMING UP WITH A PLAN BUT
WE'RE GONNA NEED A PLAN. AND
APPOINTED THIS BILL. IS TO HELP
YOU COME UP WITH THAT PLAN. AND
YOU COME UP WITH A PLAN. JUST
SHOW THAT- YOU CAN HAVE CLEAN
AFFORDABLE WATER. THAT'S GREAT
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED TO DO. IF
YOU CAN'T COME UP WITH THE PLAN
THEN WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
WATER BOARD TO DO MORE. SO THIS
IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO GET ON
BOARD. TALK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE. THE SO GIVEN THAT I AM
AND I'VE- RECOMMENDING IT I
WITH THE STRENGTHENING OF THE
BALLOT. AND THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
LOT MORE DISCUSSION GOING TO
GOING ON WITH STAKEHOLDERS I
KNOW THE AUTHOR EXTREMELY WELL
AND SHE WILL BE GLAD TO WORK
WITH YOU BUT AGAIN THIS IS FOR
YOUR BENEFIT FOR YOU. TO
DETERMINE YOUR FATE AND PLEASE
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS. WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE EIGHTY ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
CRISTINA GARCIA THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CORK BY CORK HI SMITH. SMITH
NOT VOTING ARAMBULA. OUR QUE
HAN OUR QUE HAN HI DALY. DOW
NOT VOTING CRISTINA I CHRIS
GARCIA I. BLOOM BLOOM I. MATHIS
MATHIS NAH VOTING WHAT A TO G.
WHAT TO GI. THAT HAS BY BOTH.
VERY GOOD YOU'RE OUT. SO I I'M
GOING TO PRISON. AND THEN MR
ODOM WILL. AND THE SHOULD TAKE
PROBABLY NOT TWENTY SO WE WILL
MISTER RAMSAY HERE- SOME
PROBABLY AFTER LET THIRTY- TO
FOR UP- THE. THE ON ALL OF THE
SO PLEASE GET TOMORROW MISTER
EXCUSE ME DOCTOR HERE- BY
SHORTLY AFTER LOW THIRTY. ALL
RIGHT I'M GOING. TO MY VICE
TELLS ME HE DOES REALLY TO GET
HE KNOWS HOW TO PAY ON IT TO-
SO MY- GOOD FRIEND HE- MISTER
SMITH WELL- TAKE OF. I RUN AT
THE MEETING AND- HOPEFULLY. HE
ENJOYS IT BECAUSE HE FOR A LOT
OF MEETINGS THIS IS JUST ONE
LIKE IT THANK YOU FOR THE SUPER.
OF SEPARATES SO THANK YOU MR
VICE. BILL. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE. SO WE'VE HAD A SO MERCURY
FROM THERMOMETERS STAT
THERMOSTATS- USED TO BE THAT
WAS THE ONLY KIND OF THERMOSTAT
YOU HAVE. AND WE'VE ALL HEARD
HOW. MERCURY IS NOT SAFE AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE LANDFILLS WHICH
ARE NOT CAPABLE OF KEEPING THEM
MERCURY OUT OF THE GROUND
WATER- OF ESCAPING THE LANDFILL
SO THIS IS A REALLY SERIOUS
PROBLEM. BOTH SIDES ON THIS THE
ADVOCATES FOR COLLECTING THE
MERCURY AND KEEPING OUR-
LANDFILLS- SAFE END THE
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE TAKEN
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS AGREE
THE CURRENT PROGRAM ISN'T GOING
WELL AT ALL THAT IS JUST NOT
BEING EFFECTIVE. AND I AM VERY
PLEASED THAT MY STAFF
PARTICULARLY PAGE BROKAW- I
COMMITTEE STAFFER. HAS TAKEN
AND STARTED TALKING TO THESE
GROUPS TO TRY AND COME UP WITH
A SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE. WE ALL AGREE ON THAT.
AGAIN IT COMES DOWN TO DOLLARS.
CAN WE CAN UP. WITH A BETTER
SYSTEM- AND KEEP IT DIDN'T
APPROPRIATE FINANCIAL LEVEL.
WE'RE STARTING THIS BY SAYING
ALL RIGHT WHAT IS THE IDEAL
PROGRAM WHAT WOULD YOU REALLY
NEED TO DO. AND THEY WERE GOING
TO DETERMINE WHAT THE COST OF
THAT PROGRAM ARE. AND WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AT VARIOUS OPTIONS
AND TRYING TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT IS FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE AND THAT WILL WORK.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. SO IT IS WORK IN
PROGRESS. AND WE SHALL- BUT NOW
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR. FROM THE.
FOR MY WITNESSES. AND LOOKS
LIKE I DON'T HAVE A LIST OF WHO
THE WITNESSES ARE BUT I COULD
PROBABLY DO ON THEM YES WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
TESTIFYING ON THE PHONE LINE IN
THE PHONE MODERATOR CAN YOU
CALL A J. SINCE SHE TOMORROW-
WE HAVE A NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. IT IS A THREE YEAR OLD
YOUR LINE SIR. BOHAT THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBER- SMELTER HERE.
WHICH SHALL EUREKA REGIONAL
LAYING- BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL IN THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL FOR PLEASED TO
BE WORKING WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK- ON EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN
WHICH WERE FORMED CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAM TO COLLECT AND RECYCLE
MERCURY THERMOSTATS. MY CLIENTS
IN THE TRC THE THERMOSTAT
RECYCLING CORPORATION MIGHT
HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS AS TO
WHY THE CURRENT PRODUCER RUN
PROGRAMS FAILED TO LIVE UP TO
EXPECTATIONS BUT WE ARE HERE TO
LITIGATE THE PAST. AND WE'RE
HERE TO FIND SOLUTIONS MAKE THE
PROGRAM WORK FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE WORKING WITH
FAMILY MEMBER COWORKER- ON THE
BILL AND WE HOPE THAT
EVENTUALLY THE BILL WILL BE IN
A FORM THAT WE CAN PROBABLY
SUPPORT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. LOOKING
AHEAD JUST VERY QUICKLY NOTING
THE MOTION AND A SECOND- WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
BILL HAS A FEW QUALITY
BENCHMARKS IN THE FUTURE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN SHOULD
CONTINUE TO REFLECT. THE
PRINCIPLES OF PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY I JUST I SHOULD
IMPROVE FREE AND CONVENIENT
DROP OFF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HOMEOWNERS CONTRACTORS AND
OTHERS YOU NEED TO RETURN A
THERMOSTAT. IT NEEDS TO BE
FUNDED SUFFICIENTLY TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT SENSE THE IDEA
HERE IS TO HAND OFF THE PROGRAM
TO DO NOT THE MANUFACTURERS-
WITH THE KIND OF A CERTAIN
FUNDING LEVEL. IF FOR WHATEVER
REASON THIS NEW ENTITY
COLLECTION MORE THERMOSTATS
THEN WERE- BUDGETED FOR THE
FUNDING NEEDS TO COME THROUGH
TO APPROPRIATELY PROCESS
RECYCLE THOSE THERMOSTATS SO
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT A HARD CAP ON FUNDING AND
THEN FINALLY PUBLIC AT G.
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH MUST BE
IMPROVED SO PEOPLE KNOW. WHERE
TO DROP- THE THERMOSTAT SO
AGAIN THANK YOU TO MR QUIRK I
AND HIS STAFF WE AGREE- THE
PROCESS IS BANNED- QUITE
HELPFUL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATIONS
AND WE ARE DR- TODAY SO THESE
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS CAN
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK NO
PHONE MONITOR. PLEASE CALL ON.
GILSON ON BEHALF THE THERMOS
REACHED. CORP GOOD MORNING- BY
KAREN MEMBERS CASSIE GALPIN
WITH ACCU ADVISERS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN A SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF THE THERMOSTAT
RECYCLING CORPORATION AND THE
THERMOSTAT RECYCLING
CORPORATION WAS FOUNDED A
DECADE OR SO BEFORE CALIFORNIA
BANNED THE SALE OF MERCURY
THERMOSTATS SO MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO. BY A GROUP OF
LIKE IF THE MERCURY THERMOSTAT
MANUFACTURERS AT THE
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION TO
FACILITATE AND MANAGE THE
COLLECTION IMPROPER DISPOSAL OF
MERCURY THERMOSTATS. AT TODAY
WITH MORE THAN A DECADE OF
EXPERIENCE RUNNING THE PROGRAM
THAT'S MISTER SMELSER SAID. AND
CHAIR PRECLUDED IT HAS BECOME
CLEAR TO EVERYONE INVOLVED THAT
THE ASSUMPTIONS UNDERLYING THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM SPECTER
STRUCTURE HAVE NOT FOR NOW BUT
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT. BECAUSE
THE PROGRAM IS NOT MET ANYONE
EXPECTATIONS STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
NOW LL COME TOGETHER TO
COLLABORATE ON EIGHTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN TO UPDATE THE PROGRAM SO
IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE- I WILL QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF FACTS AND
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
FIRST AT MERCURY THERMOSTATS.
WERE BANNED FROM BEING SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA. FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
AND MOST MANUFACTURERS SELLING
THEM LONG BEFORE THE BAND SO
I'M LIKE CARPET OR MATTRESS
RECYCLING THE PROGRAM IS GOING
AFTER AN EVER SHRINKING
UNIVERSE OF REMAINING MERCURY
THERMOSTATS. THIS MEANS THAT
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE UPDATE
THE PROGRAM THIS YEAR SO THAT
WE CAN. WE CAN USE THE IMPROVED
PROGRAM IMMEDIATELY AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS WHEN THE AST OF
THE MERCURY THERMOSTATS ARE
LIKELY TO BE REMOVED TO
UPGRADES REMODELED AND
DEMOLITION- IN CLOSING I'D LIKE
TO THANK CHAIRMAN QUIRK AND HIS
STAFF. FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION OF THE
TRIP MISTER SMELSER AND MY
FELLOW STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR
COLLECTIVE WILLINGNESS TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
PERSPECTIVES AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO RETRACT THE
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THE STATE'S
REMAINING MERCURY THERMOSTATS.
CAN BE COLLECTED MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EQUITABLY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND ASPIRIN I
VOTE THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. BUT THIS TIME I'LL INVITE
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. FOR MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE WITNESS I
DON'T KNOW ON THE PHONE LINE.
IT EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB. SEVEN OH SEVEN- TRIED
AGAIN PHONE MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ONE ON THE LINE AND
SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN OH SEVEN YEAH. YES ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR- TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS KRISTIN OLD SEND ON
BEHALF OF GREEN MANUFACTURING
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRMAN AND AUTHORS WORK ON
THIS MATTER AS WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. THANK YOU AND AS
A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN. ONE THIRTY FOUR. THERE'S
NO OIL NOBODY ELSE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. MAKE
SURE. AND AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION. ORDER
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN. AND NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME I'LL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SAY NOT.
GETTING CLOSE TO LUNCH TIME.
POLITICS I'LL ADVICE YOU TO
CLOSE MR CORP. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR- WE'RE AT A POINT
WHERE I BELIEVE WE DO KNOW THE
KIND OF PROGRAM WE WANT AND NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
PRICE AND- WE'LL GO FROM THERE.
CELLAIGH ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND TWO
PASSES OVER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SEVEN OH
SEVEN CORK. THE MOTION IS IT DO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK. OUR WORK ICE SMITH YES
SMITH I ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN
OUR QUE HAN HI DELHI. DALY NOT
VOTING CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA HI BLOOM- HI MATHIS
MATHIS I WANTED TO G. WHEN I TO
XII. SEVEN SEVEN THAT YEAH HE'S
OUT YOU ALL VERY MUCH. MOVED
WILL THAT CAN. IT'S JUST A
LAWYER. OKAY SO O'DONNELL
ACTUALLY ASKED TO HAVE A BILL
COME OFF CONSENT SO WE COULD
PRESENT IT UP ALL THE ALL THE
BETTER BE ENTERTAINING. THANK
YOU MR HERE THIS IS JUST A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT
I SEE SOME OTHER MEMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY ALL MEMBERS. WHO
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT DDT
AND WHERE IT ENDS UP- MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO RESENT AJ ARE TOO
WHICH CALLS UPON CONGRESS AND
THE FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY SHOULD TAKE
ALL MEASURES NECESSARY. TO
PREVENT A DDT DUMPING SITE AND
MY DISTRICT NEAR CATALINA
ISLAND FROM CAUSING FURTHER
HARM TO OUR OCEANS AND
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS. ONCE
CHAMPIONS FOR ITS USE AS A
PESTICIDE TODAY DDT IS
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE FIRST.
MAJOR ECOLOGICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH DISASTERS IN THE HISTORY
OF CHEMICAL ENGINEERING. AND A
LOT OF YOUNGER FOLKS ACTUALLY
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT DTS I JUST
KEEP IT SHORT AND SAY IT'S BAD
IT'S BAD. WE'LL EXPOSE LONG
TERM G. T. WILL OFTEN DEVELOP
PERMANENT NERVOUS SYSTEM DAMAGE
AND IF PREGNANT. CAN HAVE AN
INCREASED LIKELIHOOD OF
PREMATURE BIRTHS. AS FOR
WILDLIFE THE EFFECTS OF DDT I
BELIEVE TO HAVE LED TO THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF NUMERACY BIRDS
FROM THE CHANNEL ISLANDS
INCLUDING SPECIES OF GULLS
PELICANS AND CORMORANTS. THIS
IS A THIS IS TRULY DEVASTATING
TO OUR FRAGILE OCEANIC
ECOSYSTEMS AS DDT IS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO REMOVE FROM THE
FOOD CHAIN AS IT BUILDS UP AND
THE FATTY TISSUES OF VARIOUS
SPECIES. ALL THESE PROBLEMS
HAVE BEEN MADE EVEN WORSE BY
THE CARELESSNESS OF THOSE
ORIGINALLY TASKED WITH
DISPOSING OF THESE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
SCIENTISTS FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA'S BARBER BOB PUBLISHED
THEIR FINDINGS FROM A MULTI
YEAR EXAMINATION OF A SITE ON
THE OCEAN FLOOR JUST NORTH OF
CATALINA ISLAND. THEY
DISCOVERED A LONG FORGOTTEN
DUMPING GROUND FOR TOXICS WASTE
PRODUCED AS A BY PRODUCT OF THE
DDG MANUFACTURING PROCESS
THROUGH THE USE OF UNDERWATER
SUBMERSIBLES THE SCIENTISTS
WERE ABLE TO PROVE. WHAT IT
ONLY BEEN RUMORED BEFORE THAT
THOUSANDS OF BARRELS FILLED
WITH DDT LACED SLUDGE WERE
BARGED OUT OVER THE OPEN OCEAN
AND TOSSED INTO THE WATER JUST
TOSS OFF A SHIP. IN SOME
INSTANCES THE BERYL'S APPEARED
TO HAVE BEEN FIRST STRUCK WITH
AN AXE OR HAMMER. BY THOSE
ORIGINALLY DISPOSING OF THEM TO
ENSURE THAT THEY WOULD SINK. TO
THE OCEAN FLOOR. A PRACTICE
THAT NEARLY GUARANTEED THEIR
TOXIC CONTENTS WOULD SEEP OUT
INTO THE SURROUNDING FRAGILE
WATERS. SCIENTISTS ESTIMATE
THAT MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY TONS OF WASTE COULD HAVE
GONE INTO THE WATERS AROUND
CATALINA. IN ORDER TO BE PROPER
STEWARDS OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES WE MUST WRESTLE WITH
THE MISTAKES OF THE PAST AND
ADDRESS THE DAMAGE BEFORE IT
GETS WORSE. AG ARE TWO CALLS
UPON OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
TAKE ALL NECESSARY STEPS TO
TALK. TO STOP THE HARM THIS
SITE CONTINUES TO INFLICT ON
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENCE AND ARE
FRAGILE WILDLIFE. WITH THAT
BACK YOU MISTER CHAIR THERE
MAYBE SOMEONE FROM CATALINA
ISLAND ON THE PHONE I'M NOT
SURE WE TRY TO GET THE MAYOR
BUT THERE WAS. SOME
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES WHEN YOU
LIVE ON AN ISLAND THAT HAPPENS
OKAY- SO YES. SOMEONE IS
PROBABLY GOING TO BE ON THE
LINE FROM THE CITY OF AVALON
EITHER. MAYOR AND MARSHALL OR
ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER. MICHAEL
HARMER. IF EITHER ONE OF YOU IS
ON THE LINE PLEASE COME ON
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND SPEAK ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. IN
THE MORNING MAKE FIVE CHAIR
WORK AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MIKE
PARMER AND I AM THE ASSISTANT
CITY MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF
APPLE ON. ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TO. AVALON IS AN
ISLAND COASTAL COMMUNITY
LOCATED ON CATALINA ISLAND
ABOUT TWENTY TWO MILES OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ONE IS A LITTLE
OVER TWO POINT EIGHT SQUARE
MILES IN SIZE AND HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE YEAR ROUND WITH OVER ONE
POINT ONE MILLION VISITORS PER
YEAR. WITH OVER SIXTY TWO MILES
OF UNDEVELOPED COASTLINE NINE
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS AND POOR AREAS
OF SPECIAL BIOLOGICAL
SIGNIFICANCE THE ISLAND IS ALSO
HOME TO MORE THAN SIXTY PLANT
ANIMAL AND INSECT SPECIES FOUND
NOWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD. AS
WELL AS MANY PROTECTED SPECIES
MARINE LIFE THE CITY IN
CATALINA ISLAND HAVE A VIBRANT
TOURISM AND RECREATION BASED
ECONOMY THAT PLAYS A MAJOR ROLE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR
OCEAN COURSE ICONOMI. AB ONE IN
IRELAND ALSO HAVE A VERY STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
PHILOSOPHY AND ERIC MISSION OF
PROTECTING COASTAL RESOURCES
AND YOU NEED STATE AND FEDERAL
SAFEGUARDS THAT HELP PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT FROM POLLUTION
AND PRESERVE WATER QUALITY. AS
AN ISLAND PHYSICALLY ISOLATED
FROM CALIFORNIA MAINLAND BY THE
PACIFIC OCEAN WATER QUALITY IN
OCEAN CONSERVATION IS CRITICAL
TO THE PHYSICAL AND ECONOMIC
WELL BEING OF OUR COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER THE REDISCOVERY OF THE
DDT WASTE DUMPING SITE OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST IN THE ST
PETER BASS AND POSE A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO VIOLENCE
MARINE LIFE. OUR RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS HELP AND OUR FUTURE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY WITH THE
POLITICAL LOGICAL IMPACTS OF A
MASSIVE DDT WASTE DUMPING SITE
ARE STILL BEING ASSESSED
CRITICAL STATE AND FEDERAL
SUPPORT IS NEEDED TO CLEAN UP
THE SITE. AB ONE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED AJ ARE
TOO AND STRONGLY ENCOURAGES FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TAKE ALL
NECESSARY MEASURES TO PREVENT
FURTHER DAMAGE PROTECT AND
PRESERVE OUR VULNERABLE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. THANK.
YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. VERY GOOD- IS
THERE ANYONE- BEING THEIR
PRIMARY SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION.
IF SO- PLEASE- SAY SOMETHING TO
THE OPERATOR. I DON'T THINK
THERE IS ANYONE IN PRIMARY
OPPOSITION- IS OR ANYONE FOR OR
AGAINST THIS IN THE HALL AND I
DON'T SEE ANYONE ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IF YOU'RE THERE
AND IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
PLEASE SPEAK UP NOW. OKAY THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND LET ME FIRST HEAR
FROM PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF A J.
R. TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR AJ
ARE TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MR CAROLINE EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE EIGHTY PLEASE ON
MUTE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS ANDREA EVAN TURNER WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION EXPRESSING
OUR SUPPORT I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO- VOICE SUPPORT FOR
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
ONE NINE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE TERM MEMBERS JUST MILAN ON
BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY THE
SANTA MONICA BASED ORGANIZATION
AND THE TEAM SEES LOBBY
COALITION WITH THE T. LEVIN
MEMBERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HAVE A
STRUCTURE IS NOT OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. VERY GOOD ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR
EIGHT J. R. TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AJ ARE TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP THE STRUCTURE ALL
RIGHT MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER DONNA FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION- BEFORE SAKE DIDN'T
EVEN REALIZE YOU'RE WORKING ON
THIS- I WOULD HAVE ASKED YOU.
IF I COULD BE A JOINT AUTHOR ON
ON THIS RESOLUTION WITH YOU I
MEAN THIS IS AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED THIS IS A- ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ENVIRONMENTAL CRIMES.
THAT THAT I'M AWARE OF IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT WAS THE SUBJECT
OF A FRONT PAGE LA TIMES-
ARTICLE AND A LOT OF THOSE DDT
FILLED BARRELS WERE JUST DUMPED
RIGHT OFF THE COAST OF MY
DISTRICT OFFER THE PALACE
VERDES PENINSULA AND- YOU KNOW
I WENT AS FAR AS- ENQUIRING
WITH THE- THE U. S. EPA WAS
CENTER DIANNE FEINSTEIN'S
OFFICE AND OTHERS ABOUT- YOU
KNOW WHETHER THAT DDT IS. IS
POSING A HARM TO. ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT GO TO THE BEACH.
AND PALACE VERDES AND TORRANCE
IN REDONDO. AND WHILE I'VE BEEN
ASSURED THAT THAT IT- DOES NOT.
THERE'S NOT BEEN. A HARMFUL
LEVELS OF DDT- THE DETECTED- IN
THE BEACH GOING AREAS- NONE THE
LESS YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE LEFT
WITH. YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF BARRELS- JUST
LYING ON THE OCEAN FLOOR. OFF
THE COAST OF THE PALACE VERDES
PENINSULA SO. YOU KNOW THOSE
PEOPLE. OUGHT TO BE PROSECUTED
THEY ARE THEY ARE TO BE-
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE- YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE.
THERE BEEN LEGAL SETTLEMENTS
THAT- YEAH. MAYBE- PRESENT SOME
ISSUES BUT- BUT AS FAR AS THIS
RESOLUTION. I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER ADDING ME AS A
JOINT AUTHORS OF THIS.
ABSOLUTELY MY TO MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM TORRANCE AND I KNOW YOU
ARE IN THOSE WATERS OFTEN ON
YOUR SURFBOARD. AND THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
CRIME AND AN ENVIRONMENTAL
TRAGEDY. THE RECOGNIZING THAT
TODAY YEAH- SO- WILL
AUTOMATICALLY ADD YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR YOU COULD TALK TO THE
AUTHOR LATER AS TO BECOMING A
JOINT AUTHORS- MISTER BLOOM.
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL- I THINK MISTER
OF MURATSUCHI SENATE WELL THIS
IS A- A CRIME OF THE HIGHEST
DEGREE OF AND- I'M NOT
CRITICIZING YOU MISTER JOHN ALL
OF YOU- SAID I THINK HE IS THE
WORD THAT THAT DATE BARRELS
WERE DISPOSED CARELESSLY BOB
THIS WASN'T A CARELESS ACT TO-
IT IT WAS DONE PURPOSEFULLY IT
WAS DONE- TO SAVE FUEL TO MAKE
IT EASIER ON THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE- SUPPOSED TO BE PROPERLY
DISPOSING THESE AND- THERE.
THERE MAY BE SETTLEMENTS IN
PLACE. THE SETTLEMENTS ASSUMED
PROPER DISPOSAL AND THIS WAS
ANYTHING BUT SO I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THAT- OF THOSE ARE
RESPONSIBLE OF WILL BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE DISPOSAL AND I
CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR A
BRING IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MAYBE A
BETTER WAY TO TERMINUS HEINOUS
AND PURPOSEFUL. NOW YOU'RE ON.
ALL RIGHT OTHER COMMENTS. THERE
MIGHT BE NO OTHER WITNESSES AND
NO OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE- YOU MAY CLOSE I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS THAT'S WHEN I VOTE. ALL
RIGHT SO THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THE THING THAT MAKES
DDT DIFFERENT. IS THAT IT STAYS
SO LONG IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
BY THE WAY IT'S NOT THE ONLY
AND WE'RE PRODUCING OTHER
CHEMICALS WERE BEING MORE
CAREFUL ABOUT OUR PESTICIDES-
DDT WAS LOOKED AT AS BEING A
MIRACLE. AND THEN. WE LOST
NEARLY ALL THE BALD EAGLES ALL
BALD EAGLES AND WE FOUND IT IS
BECAUSE DDT PERSISTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THAT'S THE REAL
THREAT HERE. YOU CAN WAIT
DECADES AND IT'S STILL THERE
FURTHER ABOUT THE ESTIMATES
RIGHT NOW OR THAT HALF OF THE
INSECT LIFE IN THE WORLD. HAS
GONE AWAY- YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
IF YOU WERE A CHILD AND YOU
WERE DRIVING ON THE FREEWAY
THAT THERE WOULD BE ALL SORTS
OF INSECTS HITTING THE SHIELD
THE SHIELD OF YOUR CAR HAPPENS
TO MUCH LESS EXTENT NOW AND THE
RESULT OF FEWER INSECTS AS FAR
FEWER BIRDS. SO THIS IS. THIS
IS IMPORTANT AND IT'S SYMBOLIC
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING. TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT SO DIRE URGENT HIGH
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AJ ARE TWO OF
DONALD. THE ACTION IS BE
ADOPTED TO THE FLOOR QUIRK I
WORK I SMITH. SMITH I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BARRICADE. OUR QUE
HAN HI DALY DALY AYE CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI
BLOOM. BLOOM I MATHIS. MATHIS I
WOULD HAVE TO G. WHEN I TO GI
SO IT'S UNANIMOUS NINE ZERO.
VERY GOOD CONGRATULATIONS THANK
ARM. WILL NOW TRY AND FINISH UP
OUR WORK- ANY PARTICULAR MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD FIRST
CALLED THE BILLS THAT HAVE NOT
YET PASSED. THANK YOU. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TEN SIXTY
SIX BLOOM. THE VOTE COUNT IS
CURRENTLY THREE ONE. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I OUR QUE HAN OUR QUE
HAN I DALY DALY NOW. SO THAT'S.
IF YOU CALL AND VISIT
MURATSUCHI THAT'S RIGHT I WAS
LOOKING THERE HI. YES SIX GOOD.
SIXTEEN AND ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE GRAYSON. THE
VOTE IS AT FOUR ZERO. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HIGH POWER CAN OUR QUE
HAN I DALY DALLY NO. SO THAT'S
SIX ONE P. AND- WANTED TO G.
I'M SO SORRY. I YES SO THAT'S
SEVEN ONE HE'S NOT USED TO BE
AT THE END OF THE ALPHABET.
YEAH I WAS DOING THE MATH THE
MATH THE MATH DIDN'T MAKE SENSE
SO AND THAT'S HOW WE CATCH
OURSELVES ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN.
ROBERT RIVAS THAT HAS A VOTE OF
FOUR THREE CURRENTLY. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA NOT VOTING. MODI TWO
G. I'M ON AB THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN ROBERT RIVAS WAS NOT
VOTING AND CHANGING VOTE TO HI.
SO THAT CHANGES THE VOTE TO
FIVE THREE SO THAT VOTE THAT A
BILL PASSES OUT. ALL RIGHT THEN
WE'LL FINISH UP THE OTHER
DETAILS OKAY WE'RE GOING. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT FIVE ZERO. DR
ARAMBULA. I AM BLACK PARA QUE
HAN. OUR QUE HAN HI DALY. DALY
AYE MURATSUCHI- WHAT CITY I.
NINE ZERO. ITEM NUMBER THREE A
IS AB THREE EIGHTEEN LEVINE.
THE VOTE IS AT SEVEN ZERO.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BARRICADE
BARRICADE HENTAI SO THAT'S.
NINE ZERO. THE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
IS AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
CRISTINA GARCIA. THE PHOTO THE
VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SO THAT BRINGS IT
TO SIX. ZERO THE ITEM NUMBER
SIX IS AB SEVEN OH SEVEN CORK.
THAT IS AT SEVEN ZERO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI. THAT BRINGS IT. TO
EIGHT ZERO. OUR BUSINESS IS
DONE THANK YOU I KNOW YOU HAD
TO THE CONFLICT TODAY DR
ARAMBULA THANK YOU FOR BEING
ABLE TO MAKE IT WE NEED TO DO
HERE. SO THANK YOU AGAIN. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
HEARING WERE ACTUALLY- CLOSING
MORE LESS ON TIME. GOOD LUCK
GOOD GOOD WORK EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. RIGHT.